So, da bin ich.
Warte mal, mal was gucken.
Pog, pog, pog, pog, pog.
Äh, was ist das hier?
Okay.
Ja, okay.
So, okay. Nice.
Ha, ha!
Guck dir das Stream an, da ist irgendwelches Gespam am Start.
Alter.
Noch bevor Modkiss am Start sind.
Das Selbstlöschen.
Ja, ähm.
Das hat mich jetzt etwas aus dem Konzept gebracht.
Ich hatte gerade irgendwas im Kopf,
wo ich gedacht habe, ey, das muss ich euch mal erzählen,
aber, ja,
da komme ich bestimmt gleich wieder drauf.
Ach ja,
die ganzen Sachen, die ich beim Prime Day bestellt habe,
sind mittlerweile da.
Also, die Steckdosen sind da.
Die, was habe ich denn alles bestellt?
Die, ich muss mal kurz bei Amazon reingucken.
Sekunde, Leute.
Ich weiß schon gar nicht, was da alles dabei ist.
Ah ja, ah ja.
Genau, also.
Die Steckdosen.
Die Milf...
Die Milfrasteckdosen.
Der Name macht mich immer noch fertig.
Die Steckdosen sind da.
Das Thermostat ist da.
Der Presence-Detection-Sensor ist da.
Der Thread-Stick
ist da.
Ja.
Und das andere Zeug ist nicht relevant.
Für hier, für den Stream.
Ein Problem gibt es allerdings mit den Steckdosen.
Ich habe es gestern
schon mal ganz kurz ausprobiert.
Also, ich rede hier...
Das Einzige, das ich hier
nach diesen...
nach diesen
Buchstaben im Stream suche.
Ich habe so einen Billigpack
Steckdosen bestellt bei Amazon.
Für 9€, nicht 39,99.
Das gab es beim Prime Day
für 9€.
Für 9€,
weil es gab es billiger
Steckdosen am Prime Day.
Und es gab es nochmal irgendwie 10%
oder 20% billiger mit irgendeinem
Coupon oder so dabei.
Also 50% billiger sogar.
Also ich habe 9€ bezahlt für 4 Steckdosen.
Was ich gestern gemacht habe,
ich habe gestern mal ganz, ganz auf die Schnelle
im Raspberry Pi versucht
OTA zu flashen. OTA flashen hat nicht
funktioniert, aber
ich habe eine davon
aufgeschraubt. Ich habe die jetzt hier gerade vor mir.
Man sieht glaube ich...
Ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Wie hießen die Dinger?
KS520
oder so?
Ich habe es vergessen, wie die Dinger
hießen. Steht da irgendwas?
KS501
Es gibt nämlich Leute, die haben davon schon Bilder
gemacht. So sieht das von innen aus.
Und was man hier schön sieht ist,
guckt mal,
bei mir, also bei ihm und bei mir
ist da ein alter
Bekannter drauf.
Hier oben. Erkennt ihr es, was es ist?
Die Beleuchtung bei dem ist ein bisschen schlecht auf dem Bild.
Aber das
Logo kennt ihr wahrscheinlich.
Das ist ein ESP
8266.
Das heißt, der ist prinzipiell noch
kompatibel mit Tasmota.
Das ist wirklich klein.
Das ist sehr integriert
hier. Was ich gefunden
habe ist, die haben
tatsächlich
unter den
Ach, gucke mal.
Auf dem Bild hat er das gar nicht.
Im Moment ist
die falsche Seite.
Nee, doch, richtig.
Er hat das nicht. Okay, nice.
Wisst ihr was? Ich habe
Debuganschlüsse auf meiner
Steckdose drauf. Die sind
genau hier
drunter.
Also entweder bin ich blind oder bei dem
Modell, wo er fotografiert hat, gab es die noch
nicht. Ich habe hier Debuganschlüsse
dran.
Das heißt, wenn wir Glück haben,
können wir es darüber flashen.
Ich zeige euch das. Wir machen heute Abend ein bisschen Bastel
Bastelstrieb oder mal gucken, ob man das heute Abend noch hinhaut.
Hier habe ich Debuganschlüsse.
Hat er nicht.
Mit
3,3 Volt, RX, TX,
Ground und Reset.
Das sollte theoretisch, außer wir müssen
es sollte theoretisch zum Flashen
hiervon reichen. Ich bin mal gespannt.
Das gucken wir uns heute Abend mal an, ob das funktioniert.
Ob ich das mit einem
Serial Flash
Gerät geflasht bekomme.
Was sein kann, wo wir echt
Probleme haben, Probleme
haben werden, ist
wenn GPIO 0
GPIO 0 ist der
hier, wenn man den auf
Ground machen muss, dass man flashen kann.
Dann wird es schwierig, weil das ist so mikroskopisch
klein.
Das kriege ich wahrscheinlich nicht gebacken.
Aber das schauen wir uns mal
mal gucken, ob ich es
heute Abend noch mache, aber ich hätte Bock
das auszuprobieren.
Also ein Flash
Champion mit ein paar Steckdosen.
Aber schon lange nicht mehr gemacht.
Wie gesagt, eine habe ich
auseinandergebaut und
die sah halt wirklich ganz genau so aus.
Es ist
wirklich so, außer dass ich hier oben
Debuganschlüsse habe und er nicht.
Oder wie nennt man das?
Ja, doch, Debuganschlüsse.
Das haben die China-Chinesen
das Ganze schon mal
bisschen ordentlicher gemacht.
Ja, schade, dass es nicht OTA-flashbar
ist. Oder ich habe es nicht
richtig ausprobiert. Das können wir nachher
auch mal ausprobieren.
Manchmal
muss man das OTA-Flashen ja 3-4 Mal
probieren, bis es funktioniert.
Naja.
Aber,
nur so das am Rande.
Ja, mir fällt immer noch nicht ein, was ich ursprünglich erzählen wollte.
Lasst uns mal einen
Blick in die GitHub-Trends
dieser Woche werfen. Lasst mich raten.
AI, AI
und bisschen Crypto-Shit.
AI, ja, geht schon los.
AI, AI
AI, nee.
Keine Ahnung.
HTMLX
AI
Comfy UI
AI, was sonst?
A server software
re-implementation for a certain anime game.
Ist das nicht
dieses Genshin Impact
Projekt hier?
Wo sie nicht erwähnen dürfen, dass es
damit zu tun hat?
Nicht so spannend heute.
Ja, das ist seit Monaten
nur AI. Das hört gar nicht mehr auf.
Wobei,
je nachdem, wo man guckt,
also wenn man jetzt mal explizit zum Beispiel zu
Javascript gehen,
dann gibt es tatsächlich wieder die 0815
Javascript
Libraries. Hier, guckt euch das an.
HTMLX gibt es jetzt.
HTMLX High Power
Tools for HTML.
Wie gesagt, es vergehen keine
drei Tage
für neue Javascript, wobei eigentlich
eher drei Javascript Frameworks an einem Tag.
Fireship Video,
das haben wir sogar, glaube ich, noch irgendwo offen.
Vielleicht gucken wir das gleich.
AI.
Nicht so spannend.
Wir haben das Fireship Video
irgendwo offen.
Das Ding ist,
keine Ahnung, ich habe zu viel
Tabs auf.
Ja.
HTMLX.
So.
Chatgear.
Das passt bei euch.
Gab es irgendwas Spannendes?
Ich meine, ich war fast jeden Tag
on, außer gestern.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, warum sie es HTMLX und nicht
HTMLX genannt haben.
Moin.
Irgendwas Spannendes.
Heiße hatte mal irgendwer. Achso, ja,
eine...
Achso, ich kann ja keine Twitter-Messages mehr vor mir aufbauen,
weil man sich einloggen muss.
Das ist so ein abgrundtief dummer
Change. Alter, das regt mich immer noch auf.
Ab jetzt nur noch
4-Tage-Woche. Dazu kann ich nur sagen,
sehr, sehr
nice. Und natürlich easy.
Easy as fuck.
Nice.
So muss das sein.
Ich habe gehört, ein Kollege von mir auf der Arbeit
macht jetzt auch Teilzeit. Wobei der, glaube ich,
nur 90% Teilzeit macht.
Es werden immer mehr, Leute. Wir werden
immer mehr.
Zu Recht, ja.
Wenn man genug Geld verdient,
dass man gut auskommt, auch mit 4 Tagen,
warum sollte man 5 Tage arbeiten?
Ganz simple
Geschichte, oder? Sobald man dann mehr
Zeit hat, sich um seine eigenen Sachen zu kümmern.
Und ich ja mit dem anderen Krempel auch noch
nebenbei ein paar, den ein oder anderen
Euro verdienen kann. Also insofern.
Also für mich ist es nach wie vor
das Beste, was es gibt,
Teilzeit zu arbeiten.
Amerikanischer Arbeitgeber
war verwirrt. Ja, der ist
wahrscheinlich schon verwirrt, dass du abends überhaupt
heimfahren willst.
Und nicht noch bis 22 Uhr auf
dem, ja, wie auch immer
man das nennt,
Betriebsgelände
unterwegs sein willst und dort dann
irgendwelche Dinger
machen möchtest.
So wie man das teilweise in Videos sieht, so nach dem Motto
Ja, jetzt gehen wir erst nochmal
ins Firmen eigene Fitnessstudio.
Es ist schon 21.30 Uhr,
aber benügt's. Und dann machen wir
Karaoke mit den...
Alter Leute, was ist mit euch los?
16 Uhr haue ich ab, gehe ich heim,
wenn ich nichts mehr mit der Arbeit zu tun habe.
Seid ihr nicht dafür bezahlt?
Was bei uns hat man jetzt?
Eine 39-Stunden-Woche eingeführt.
Es gibt aber erstmal für ein Jahr
39,5 und erst...
Ja, dann sollen sie es auch nicht
39 Stunden nennen. Das ist geil, ne?
Leute, wir führen eine 39-Stunden-
30-Stunden-Woche ein.
Aber es sind 39,5.
Aber wir nennen es schon mal eine 39-Stunden-Woche,
weil unser Ziel wird ja sein, dass es 39
wird.
Also so Marketing, bla bla.
Oh man.
39 Stunden am Tag, jede Woche.
Korrekt, so muss das sein.
Die haben den 40-Stunden-Tag erfunden.
Du hast ja eine Stunde zum Schlafen
und deine Sachen zu machen, das reicht.
Dann geht's
weiter.
30-Stunden-Woche und das hilft auch enorm.
Auch wenn der Freitag kurz ist,
hilft er auch enorm.
Also eine Sache,
die mich ja wieder hat an der aktuellen...
Kurz zu Hause, weil ich kann ja mein eigenes Twitter
nicht mehr aufmachen.
Eine Sache, die mich auch etwas...
Was ist das hier?
Windows-Schriftrenderer. Ja, ClearType hat schon immer gesagt.
Ja.
Also eine Sache, die mich auch wieder extrem
verwirrt hat,
wie man sich sowas
überhaupt kaufen kann,
ist folgendes. Wie heißt die?
FunMove oder so?
Genau.
Es gibt einen niederländischen...
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal bei dem Namen.
Also es gibt
einen E-Bike-Hersteller,
der hat seine E-Bikes
gekoppelt mit einer Smartphone-App.
Das ist ja an sich
nicht so wild.
Das kann man ja machen, weil das über Bluetooth
kommuniziert, aber
damit das über Bluetooth direkt mit dem Fahrrad
kommunizieren kann, muss
vorher eine Verbindung zu den Cloud-Servern
hergestellt werden des Herstellers.
So.
Das alleine ist natürlich schon etwas
fragwürdig vielleicht, aber
was kann da schon schief gehen?
Ja. Das Problem ist
jetzt, dass der Hersteller
wohl eventuell demnächst
pleite geht oder demnächst dicht macht,
die Server schließt, was auch immer.
Und dann können die Leute
die App nicht mehr richtig verwenden
mit ihrem Fahrrad. Und wir reden hier jetzt nicht
etwa damit, dass du da irgendwelche komischen
Dinge machen kannst
von Fahrradorten
bis sonst was. Nein, nein.
Wir reden hier von ganz elementaren Sachen
wie die Steuerung vom Licht
und sowas. Also du kannst
dann das Licht an deinem Fahrrad
nicht mehr ordentlich benutzen,
wenn die Server
abgeschaltet werden von der Cloud.
So. Und es steht ja auch hier drinnen,
die haben finanzielle Probleme
und vielleicht machen sie die Server
dicht.
In diesem Fall würde die App nicht mehr
funktionieren und E-Bikes wichtige Funktionen
verlieren. Für dieses Szenario...
Moment, wo steht das mit dem Licht?
Hab ich das bei Golem gelesen?
Ja, genau.
Der App-Betrieb ist allerdings Voraussetzung
für wichtige Features wie die Steuerung von
Licht und Geschwindigkeit.
Also wer auf die bescheuerte
Idee gekommen ist, dass du
ein Fahrrad nur noch mit Cloud-Anbindung
richtig verwenden kannst, der gehört echt geschlagen.
Ich bin nicht für körperliche Gewalt
normalerweise, aber in dem Fall würde ich
mal eine Ausnahme machen.
Ich finde an sich das durchaus in Ordnung,
dass das Ding über Bluetooth lokal
mit dem Fahrrad kommuniziert.
Aber dass es vorher erst mal eine Cloud-Verbindung braucht,
ist halt auch schon pp-gar.
Und warum ist das?
Weil die Hersteller alle
also sie werden das mit Security begründen
oder mit irgendwelchen anderen
fadenscheinigen Sachen.
Warum ist das? Weil die Hersteller
nicht alle loginnen wollen
in ihr Ökosystem und in den Kram.
Selbst wenn es zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt gar keinen Sinn macht.
Die denken sich, wir machen erst mal
Vendor-Login, vielleicht machen
wir dann in Zukunft noch mehr damit.
Vielleicht haben wir dann demnächst noch, fragt mich nicht,
ein Skateboard oder so, was man nun damit paaren kann.
Oder irgendwelche Zusatz-Gadgets
und hast du nicht gesehen.
Erstmal wird loginnt und dann wird sich
überlegt, was machen wir
jetzt eigentlich damit.
Und hier sieht man mal wieder, die Idee,
dass ein Fahrrad nur mit Cloud-Anbindung
gescheit funktioniert, ist halt nicht so schlau.
Echt, es gibt mittlerweile Maus-Hersteller,
wo du die Maus registrieren musst,
Cloud-Sachen benutzen musst,
dass sie überhaupt funktioniert.
Das ist mir jetzt neu.
Was mich ja persönlich schon immer
richtig nervt, ist bei Nvidia
die Geschichte,
wo du jetzt neuerdings, dass du
diesen Nvidia
Geforce, wie nennt sich dieses Ding hier?
Die Geforce X, nee, nee, nicht das hier.
Das ist ja der normale Treiber.
Die Geforce Experience heißt das ja.
Also die Experience
dabei ist, dass du neuerdings einen Account brauchst.
Wobei neuerdings ist gut,
du brauchst die letzten sieben Jahre
oder so schon einen Account. Aber es ging früher auch ohne Account.
Und ich frag mich halt immer noch,
warum brauch ich eine Software,
wo ich lokal
beispielsweise Videos
Capturen kann und
Grafikkarten-Treiber-Update
machen kann, warum braucht die
zwangsläufig einen Nvidia-Account?
Man kann Bilder hochladen und sowas.
Ja, das ist okay. Aber wenn ich Bilder
hochladen will zum Sharen,
dann kann ich mir über diese Software immer noch
einen Nvidia-Account machen. Da brauch ich nicht
gezwungen werden dazu, einen Nvidia-Account
zu machen.
Total bescheuert. Und in dem Fall hat's die hier
halt erwischt jetzt, wenn die die
Server zumachen von dem Fahrradanbieter,
dann geht halt die App
nicht mehr und du kannst dein Licht und die Geschwindigkeit
vom E-Fahrrad nicht mehr einstellen.
Das ist wirklich
maximal hängen geblieben.
Mal gucken, was das Heise-Forum dazu sagt.
Das Heise-Forum
ist am
Circle-Jerken
über die App, gehe ich mal von aus.
Hat sich ausgehipstert.
Heise-Forum ist wieder am Start.
Die wollen gerne E-Mail-Adressen sammeln.
Ja, mir ist schon klar, warum die
das machen, aber aus
Kundensicht und Funktionssicht
ist es halt total dämlich.
Man braucht gar keinen Account dafür,
um lokal E-Mails
äh, lokal E-Mails
um lokal Videos aufzunehmen
und Screenshots zu machen und
Grafikkartentreiber abzudaten.
Es würde reichen,
wenn ich Bilder hochladen will, wenn man
einen Account braucht. Aber wie gesagt,
das ist das, was ich gerade erzählt hab.
Wir machen erstmal irgendwelche Vendor-gebunden
oder Hersteller-gebundenen Sachen
und dann überlegen sie sich, was könnte man damit
machen. Und die haben halt gelitten mit dem Fahrrad.
Das ist aber schwierig. Du kannst das Unternehmen
nicht dazu zwingen, das zu machen.
Also an sich, an sich schon
wahrscheinlich gesetzesmäßig
gibt's das nicht her. Und das
zweite ist, ein Unternehmen, was
kurz vor der Pleite ist, lässt sich eh schwierig
mit irgendwelchen Sachen zu irgendwas
zwingen. Weil die sagen sich, ey, wir sind
eh pleite
und das einzige, was ihr machen würdet,
ist es vielleicht noch ein bisschen zu beschleunigen.
Das kannst du
vergessen. Aber
achso, ja, eine Sache, falls jemand
äh...
Hier, eine Sache ist tatsächlich noch
ganz gut, was auch in dem
Artikel irgendwo drin stand. Es gibt auf GitHub
ein
Exporter für den Encryption-Key,
dass man keine Cloud mehr braucht. Dann gibt es quasi
custom, weiß nicht, ob man custom Firmware flashen
muss auf das Fahrrad.
Großartig hat das hochgeladen.
Großartig.io
Trau ich mich, das aufzumachen?
Der Name klingt gut.
Den finde ich nice.
Ich trau mich, das aufzumachen.
Großartig.io
Ich finde, das ist eine richtig gute
Domain. Oh, das
sieht nach Web
5.0-Webseite aus.
Guck mal, sogar die
Partikel im Hintergrund bewegen sich, wenn man
die Maus...
Seht ihr das?
Richtig krasse Hipster-Webseite.
Aber sieht auch ganz stylisch aus.
Because change needs a secure
environment.
Ach, das ist ein
Wordpress, oder? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Aber großartig hat
das anscheinend großartigerweise
programmiert. Da kann man
die Keys von
seinem E-Bike extrahieren und
dann es irgendwie auch ohne App benutzen.
Das Problem dabei ist,
dass das halt den 0815 E-Bike
User komplett überfordert.
Sagt doch mal irgendeinem Typ, der sich
Sagt doch mal einem Typ, der
sich ein E-Bike gekauft hat,
aber jetzt nicht so Computer
und Technik affin ist.
Sagt dem mal, okay, anstatt
einfach die Smartphone-App zu benutzen,
gehst du mal vorher auf GitHub,
dann lädst du dir den Funmove-Encryption-
Key-Exporter runter, dann
installierst du die Docker und startest es im
Docker-Container, dann machst du den Browser
auf, gehst dahin, verbindest das dann mit
Bluetooth mit deinem Fahrrad. Da denken
die sich dann auch, keck, wait, was will der
Kerl von mir?
Optional, use reverse
proxy, jaja, ist alles klar,
npm run, npm build.
Das macht natürlich den 0815
nicht sonderlich technikinteressierte.
Aber trotzdem ist es super, dass es
sowas gibt.
Die Playlist ist
unterschiedlich laut.
Alternativ
hat jetzt irgendein Konkurrenthersteller
was dazu angeboten, aber ganz ehrlich,
das ist the way to go, wenn man so ein
E-Bike hat und dass man unabhängig
wird von irgendwelchen komischen Kack-Cloud-
Anbindungen und solche Geschichten.
War das eigentlich nicht
dieser Fahrradhersteller, der dir ein neues Fahrrad
zur Verfügung stellt, wenn das
alt... keine Ahnung,
ich habe mich nie mit beschäftigt.
Das klingt an sich schon bescheuert,
den Key von meinem E-Bike extrahieren?
Ja,
das stimmt schon.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen,
Kack-G, da hast du recht.
Leute,
ich habe noch ein paar
7-TV-Emotes hinzugefügt.
Ich glaube,
ich muss jetzt auch mal mehr 7-TV-Emotes
benutzen.
Weil eh mittlerweile jede
Extension die Emotes der jeweils anderen
unterstützt, also
FFZ kann 7-TV,
Twitch-TV und FFZ
und bei der Twitch-TV kann FFZ, bei der Twitch-TV
wahrscheinlich auch 7-TV, 7-TV kann auch
sonst alles.
Und da kriegt man auch ein paar zusätzliche
Emotes-Slots. Ich glaube sogar
über 100 oder 500 oder so.
Unendlich, nahezu
unendlich Emotes-Slots.
Jo.
Machen wir das mal wieder dicht hier.
Achso.
Lass mich gerade noch mal kurz gucken,
was der aktuelle Trend in der
in der .NET-Welt ist.
Avalonia-Trended.
Ja, haben wir uns letztens
angeguckt. Ich fand es nicht schlecht.
Wenn vielleicht noch die einen oder anderen
Controls fehlen, zum Beispiel
ein Webview wäre ganz cool.
Klar, man kann auch immer noch einen externen Browser öffnen,
aber ein Webview wäre schon sehr nice.
Und nicht als 3rd-Party-Add-on.
Ich gette aber auch, dass die das nicht
wollen, weil das ziemliche
Abhängigkeiten
mit sich zieht.
Nach sich zieht.
Ja.
Die wohl
verbreitetste .NET-Library,
um Sachen zu overengineeren.
Maui-Trended.
Das verstehe ich nicht, warum Maui-Trended.
Ich mag Maui überhaupt nicht.
Terminal-GUI. Cross-Platform-Terminal-
UI-Toolkit. Okay.
Nice. Was können die so?
Öh!
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie
N-Curses.
Öh.
Okay.
Das ist quasi N-Curses für
PowerShell oder sowas.
Für Windows. Oder ist es Cross-Plattform?
Dann ist es
N-Curses nachgebaut
über
alles andere als Windows.
Also für
inklusive Windows, Mac,
Linux.
Ja gut.
Warum nicht, wenn man sowas mag?
Ich mag so
Terminal-GUIs nicht. Ich mag
CLI-Tools, die man ordentlich benutzen kann,
aber keine Terminal-GUIs.
Unity-Zeug.
Machine-Learning-Unity.
Blazer-Gedöns.
Message-Bus.
China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Keine Ahnung. Leaky-Office-Tools.
Und
Revoke-Message-Pedger.
Ah, ein Hex-Editor
für WeChat.
Okay, das ist China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Deluxe.
Torrent-Tracker, die wir selbstverständlich
alle nur benutzen, um Linux-Distributionen
runterzuladen.
Obviously.
Avalonia-Examples.
Space-Station-14.
Okay, Leute.
Wenn ihr ein Game macht, wäre halt
Screenshots-Extrem-Pog.
Was ist das?
Space-Station-14.
Wie was von gehört.
Garten-Kralle. Danke schön für den Sub.
So, dann haben wir einen
Discord-Chat-Exporter.
Okay, das klingt mal nach einem sinnvollen
Tool. Man kann Chat-Logs
exportieren aus Discord
in ein File.
Wer weiß, ob man in der Chat verschwindet, Discord irgendwann mal was
löscht. Auch zum besser
durchsuchen und alles. Das finde ich tatsächlich
mal eine sehr sinnvolle Geschichte.
Wie benutzt man das?
Wie benutzt man das ordentlich?
Also was?
Wie?
Maintenance-Mode. Okay.
Wie benutzt man das richtig?
Wie funktioniert das?
Aber man muss irgendeinen
Discord-Authentifizierungstoken
oder so rein
bauen.
Naja, gut.
Vielleicht braucht man das mal.
Bitwarn-Mobile-App.
Fast-Shit-App.
Für die China-Chinesen.
Poly-Poly ist nice.
Das habe ich auch schon ein paar Mal verwendet.
Power-Tools.
Ja, okay.
Ich finde immer gut, wenn man sich die
Csharpmode.net-Trends anguckt, dass es nicht zu 90%
Machine-Learning ist.
Weil ansonsten sind die GitHub-Trends
Machine-Learning, AI.
Machine-Learning, Machine-Learning, AI.
Bisschen Krypto-Zeug manchmal.
AI.
Windows finally gets native
RAR-Support. In der heutigen
Zeit, wo kaum noch eine RAR verwendet.
Leute, wann habt ihr das letzte Mal ein
RAR-Archive gebraucht?
Erzählt mal.
Ich vermute mal,
dass es bei mir noch nicht ganz so lange her ist.
Weil ich mir letztens ein paar
Sachen von Archive.org
runtergeladen habe.
Und da waren Sachen
in RAR drin. Also vielleicht 2-3
Monate her.
Aber insgesamt ist RAR-Archive schon recht
RAR.
Usenet. Ah, bestimmt auch noch
für Linux-Distributionen, oder?
Zip. Ja, ganz ehrlich.
Es ist immer noch 95%, dass es
eine Zip-Datei ist. Deswegen ist es auch richtig
gut, dass Google jetzt als Top-Level-Domain
Punkt Zip hat. Um noch mehr die Leute
zu scammen.
WinRAR, beste Anschaffung. Der Kauf hat sich gelohnt.
Naja.
Das ist eine Software, die hätte man sich vor 20 Jahren
kaufen können und heute immer noch benutzen. Ich weiß nicht,
wann gab es denn WinRAR
Version History?
Wann gab es denn da die letzte Version von?
Moment, was?
Vor 2 Monaten?
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht,
die letzte WinRAR-Version ist
von
sonst wann Uhrzeiten.
The fuck? Guck mal hier.
Das wird sogar noch regelmäßig...
Okay, man muss sagen,
seit 2013 ist ein bisschen
weniger passiert. Das sind immer ein paar Jahre
dazwischen.
Das wäre praktisch gewesen.
Da habe ich tatsächlich
mehr als RAR-Files
written in C++. Das wundert mich nicht
zur damaligen Zeit.
WinRAR. Kennt noch jemand
von euch
WinAce?
Das erste,
was du über Google findest,
ist WinAce Serial Key.
Ja, geil.
Google macht sich heute
immer Mühe, das rauszufiltern.
Kennt dieses Ding noch jemand?
Das war...
Ich weiß nicht, ob Wikipedia überhaupt einen Eintrag hat.
Das war zu Zeiten,
als man sich noch
Sicherheitskopien aus dem Internet runtergeladen hat,
vor 15-20 Jahren,
sehr angesagt...
Sagen wir vor
20-25
Jahren, war das
als WinRAR-Alternative.
Und das
letzte Stable Release ist da allerdings
schon 2007 gewesen.
Das wird nicht mehr weiterentwickelt.
Okay. WinAce.
Nur Sicherheitskopien.
Immer. Ich habe nie was anderes als
Sicherheitskopien
runtergeladen.
Das sieht ein bisschen so aus, aber ich meine die Windows-Version
davon. Und WinAce.
Also,
YouTube ist ganz...
ganz der Meinung, wir müssen das hier
angucken, aber das interessiert mich nicht.
Das gibt einen Trick, wenn man bei
YouTube das Video anklickt und gleich wieder
schließt, dann sollte YouTube checken,
dass man das nicht
sehen will. Haben wir noch
Tabs? Ja, gibt noch ein paar. Guck da.
Ich hab noch welche.
Es sind noch nicht alle Tabs
leer. Ich kann noch welche aufmachen.
Und ich hab ja auch genug
RAM. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es
überhaupt ein Limit gibt.
Also aktuell hab ich ja noch viel zu viel RAM frei.
Guck mal. 10 Gigabyte von
64. Das ist ja nix.
Sekunde, Leute. Ich muss noch
eine VM starten. Bisschen RAM.
Ihr wisst doch, wie das unter Linux so ist.
Und unter Windows gilt das gleiche.
Nicht benutzter RAM ist verschenkter RAM.
Man kann auch rechtsklick
kein Interesse wählen. Nee, kann man nicht.
Weil das geht nur, wenn man eingeloggt ist.
Unused Tabs werden
einfach gefreezed. Oh, das ist aber
sad.
Ich wollte eigentlich meinen RAM ordentlich benutzen.
Oh, guck mal. Es gibt
eine neue Go-Version. Was gibt's
Neues in Go? Go Release.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Release History.
Es gibt ein neues Go-Release. Und zwar, wann?
Irgendein
Minor-Release, was nicht weiter
juckt.
Das ist ja langweilig.
Machen wir mal kurz Update.
Dann starte ich die VM neu.
Was zum Teufel ist
nwg-look?
Was hab ich da installiert?
GitHub.
Was ist das?
Ah, GTK
Settings und sowas. Okay.
Es hat bestimmt seinen Grund,
warum ich nwg-look
versus LXAppearance
genommen habe. Wahrscheinlich, weil LXAppearance
irgendwie nicht richtig... Ah ja, ich weiß, warum.
Weil LXAppearance den Mauszeiger
nicht ändern konnte. Aber nwg-look
schon.
Ja, wir haben ab und zu schon die ein oder anderen Videos von
ihm geguckt. Aber es ist nicht so, als würde ich
jetzt da jedes Video verfolgen.
Wir hatten es ja
letztens davon, welche deutschsprachigen
IT-Channels
ich gucke.
Und ich muss sagen, ich bin immer noch der Meinung, dass
Algorithm und Verstehen bzw. Florian,
dass das der beste Channel ist im deutschsprachigen Raum.
Allerdings sind halt auch viele
Videos sehr spezifisch, wo ich sagen muss, gut, da
geht mich das Thema dahinter halt nicht. Aber wenn ich
eins gucke, finde ich, sind das mit Abstand die besten Videos.
Morpheus gucke ich auch ab und zu noch,
wenn es ein Thema ist, was mich interessiert.
Aber ansonsten...
Ich will da jetzt
keinem Unrecht tun, von dem ich vielleicht
vergesse. Ich gucke bestimmt die ein oder anderen
Videos sonst noch.
Von...
Wie heißt der? Kevin...
Chromik...
Chromik oder so gibt es noch. Von dem haben wir auch ein paar
geguckt. Ich weiß leider nicht genau, wie er heißt.
Ich lasse es mit Aussprache.
Ich habe es mir nicht gemerkt. Von dem haben wir
auch ein paar Videos letztens geguckt.
Wo er aus Spanien
Homeoffice gemacht hat.
NativeWeb. NativeWeb
ist auch Porg. NativeWeb gucke ich immer gerne.
Ja, das stimmt. Wobei ich das
nicht so
wirklich dazuzählen würde.
Die anderen machen ja auch so
ein bisschen...
IT-Lifestyle.
Kann man das so nennen?
Ich weiß nicht. Die erzählen dann auch mal
Okay, wie ist das so
Homeoffice aus Spanien zu arbeiten?
Oder beste Entscheidungen in meinem
Job und sowas. Und NativeWeb
macht halt wirklich immer nur ganz
fachlich bezogene
gut gemachte
meistens Frontend-bezogene
Technik-Videos.
Aber die gucke ich gerne an.
Hacken mit Chat-GPT.
Alter, jetzt übertreibt es halt.
Ich habe keinen Bock auf die ganzen AI-Videos mehr.
Mir reicht es irgendwann.
Ich bin wirklich komplett gesättigt, was AI-Videos
angeht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber
ich gucke mir vielleicht in der Woche noch
zwei Videos an zu dem Thema.
Aber das war's.
Das meiste ist auch einfach
nichts Neues, sondern nur
so Rehash von den
Videos, die es schon gegeben hat.
Hat er mal vielleicht
wieder ein
Tieren-Menschen-Automation
oder sowas?
Das haben wir schon geguckt.
Okay, Chat.
Wollen wir anfangen, uns ein paar Videos
reinzuhauen?
Gab's die Woche noch irgendwelche anderen spannenden
Sachen?
Was brauche ich GTK auch, wenn ich
einen anderen Window-Manager nutze als
Gnome, ja? Das ist die
UI-Library.
Eine der möglichen UI-Libraries,
in der du grafische Anwendungen unter Linux
erstellen kannst. Und wenn eine
Anwendung auf GTK aufbaut, dann brauchst
du immer GTK, egal ob du Gnome verwendest
oder nicht.
Das ist so, wie wenn du Windows Forms benutzt, im Endeffekt.
Oder sagen wir, wie wenn du
WPF benutzt. WPF ist das bessere Beispiel,
weil Windows Forms ist ja teilweise sogar direkt
mit Windows integriert. WPF aber nicht.
Das ist so, wie wenn du WPF
benutzt. Wenn du WPF benutzt,
dann ist das ja auch
die UI-Technologie.
Gut, das ist ein doofes Beispiel,
weil du kannst sie nur unter Windows laufen lassen.
Aber...
Sagen wir, du hast eine Anwendung in Avalonia gemacht.
Dann brauchst du logischerweise auch Avalonia.
Also nicht installiert,
aber halt für dein Programm,
um es zu kompilieren.
Was war das Fazit von dem diesjährigen
Prime Day? Ich glaube, ich habe irgendwie 300 Euro oder so
ausgegeben und wahrscheinlich ein paar ganz
günstige, sinnvolle Sachen gefunden.
Auf der anderen Seite allerdings auch wieder
nicht so toll, weil wahrscheinlich
werde ich die Dinger nicht brauchen.
Ich habe mir einen super billigen Pack
mit flechtbaren Steckdosen, also wahrscheinlich flechtbare
Steckdosenleisten wieder gekauft,
Heizungsthermostaten sowas, einfach zum Basteln.
Nicht, weil ich es wirklich brauche.
Ich glaube, das einzig wirklich sinnvolle,
was ich mir
gekauft habe, ist ein
Bosch Professional Tape Measure.
Also so ein Maßband.
So ein Teil zum
ausziehen.
Da habe ich nur so ein billiges Ikea-Ding und da
wollte ich schon längere
Zeit mal ein gescheites.
Ja und der neue Zigbee-Stick.
Den werde ich auch benutzen.
Hast du schon mal mit Elasticsearch
gearbeitet? Ja, habe ich.
Wir hatten auf der alten Arbeit
ups. Wir hatten auf
der alten Arbeit ein
Elasticsearch-Cluster für
Logs, sowohl
Systemlogs als auch Anwendungslogs.
Und
ich bin mir aber gar nicht mehr sicher, was
da alles noch oben, da war dann,
wie nennt sich das? Elk, oder?
Elkstack? Ist das nicht so?
Logstash! Ja, genau.
Ja, ja, ja. Ich erinnere mich.
Elast...
Kibana! Genau, ja.
Ja, ja. Die Kombination hatten wir.
Elasticsearch, Logstash, Kibana.
Der Elkstack.
Filebeat.
Filebeat hatten wir auch. Ja, genau. Genau, genau.
Ich erinnere mich. Das Ding ist aber,
ich
habe damals nicht viel damit gemacht.
Also ich weiß, dass wir... Warte mal, die Musik
ist viel zu laut. Warum?
Anzeige.
Aber ich habe damit nicht viel gemacht. Das einzige,
was ich bei uns bei Elasticsearch mitbekommen
hab, ist, dass der Elasticsearch-Support
kacke ist. Wir hatten ein paar
Mal das Problem, dass unser Cluster irgendwie keine
neuen Notes mehr aufnehmen konnte.
Und der Elasticsearch-Cluster
irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
sich auf jeden Fall auch nicht
mit Ruhm bekleckert hat.
Und es ewig, teilweise Wochen gedauert hat, bis
sich da irgendwas getan hat.
Wie ist eure Erfahrung mit Elasticsearch?
Oder fragst du jetzt für den Fall der Fälle,
weil du es einsetzen willst
und nicht genau sicher bist?
Also, das einzige,
was ich von Elasticsearch wirklich noch im Hinterkopf habe,
ist, dass es ein ziemlich komplexes Setup ist.
Ich habe, wie gesagt,
ich habe es nicht selbst installiert, ich habe es auch nicht selbst
administriert und betrieben. Nur so vom
Beobachten. Das es wohl ein sehr komplexes
Setup sein muss.
Und wo man sich wirklich fragen muss, ob
sich das echt lohnt.
Gibt ja mittlerweile auch schon ein paar Alternativen.
Also ich weiß, dass beispielsweise
von den
Grafana-Leuten gibt's
ja Loki und Promtale,
heißt das glaube ich, für Logs.
Das ist natürlich nicht mit
einem vollwertigen Elasticsearch zu vergleichen.
Sag ich jetzt mal, ohne dass ich jetzt
direkt einen Vergleich machen könnte.
Aber wenn Logs das, wenn Log
einsammeln, das ist was du machen willst, dann ist
vielleicht das die simplere Alternative.
Und was gibt's denn sonst noch?
Was gibt's denn sonst noch für...
Es gibt ja so 2-3 größere Sachen
für Log und
Fulltextsearch und sowas.
Was gibt's denn sonst noch? Splunk gibt's noch, ja genau.
Craylog, ja.
Sagt mir vom Namen her auch was.
Also Splunk kenne ich,
wo ich jetzt aktuell arbeite, haben die das.
Ich muss sagen, sonnerlich
gefeiert habe ich die Software bis jetzt aber noch nicht.
Crep ist immer noch die
beste Log-Auswertung.
Ich gebe zu, der Vergleich hinkt.
Es geht nicht über mehrere Rechner, es geht auch nicht
über Terabyte-weise
Dateien gescheit und
Kontext aus den Logs
kannst du da auch nicht erkennen.
Aber trotzdem, auf die
Schnelle ist Crep immer noch das Beste.
Oder Cat gepiped in Crep.
Auch wenn dann die ganzen
Linux-Hardcore-Leute
wieder ankommen und sagen
useless use of Cat, aber
manchmal baut man sich
halt seine Befehle so zusammen.
Also das ist ganz, ganz böse. Also wenn ihr mal irgendwie
so einen richtigen Linux-
Hardcore-Fanatiker triggern
wollt, dann macht
ihr sowas hier, cat
.kekle, Crep nach
1 zum Beispiel.
Dann wird der euch sagen,
ha, lul, was ist hier los?
Useless use of Cat,
mach doch so, das geht doch auch.
Aber oftmals baut man sich ja
seine Befehle so zusammen und dann ist es
einfach einfacher, anstatt es
eine halbe Stunde rum zu editieren.
Vielleicht soll ich die Datei mal wieder löschen, sonst
habe ich wieder so viele sinnlose Dateien rumliegen.
Habe ich eigentlich schon
rebooted jetzt nach dem Update?
Hat er alles geupdated?
Ich glaube, ich habe nicht rebooted.
Da können wir
mal kurz den peepohappy-Background
bestaunen gleich. Also
Crep-L, also groß L
kriege ich nicht zusammen, was das heißt.
Minus I ist case insensitive und minus L ist recursive
auf das komplette Dateisystem.
Pog?
Ne.
Nicht Pog.
Exzellent, der Hintergrund.
Peepo ist
gerade am essen.
Ich trinke auch mal was.
L-Liste Datei mit minus
L ohne
L. Achso.
Ja, was macht minus L?
Ohne den Pfad, oder was?
Ach, nur den Pfad.
Gestern erst mal
Standing-Desk zu Hause aufgebaut. Beste.
Also du hast wahrscheinlich einen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch.
Nicht extra einen, wo man nur
standen kann. Ich habe ja auch
einen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch.
Ich muss sagen, ich verwende das
stehen
weniger als ich sollte.
Obwohl ich alles extra so vom Setup gebaut
habe, dass die Kabel
lang genug sind und sowas.
Ich habe sogar hier neben am Tisch das Ding
liegen zum hoch- und runterfahren.
Aber ich bin zu faul.
Mit der Kurbel.
Aber mit der Kurbel hätte ich noch weniger Bock gehabt.
Hätte ich noch weniger Bock gehabt.
Exzellente Backgrounds.
Übrigens,
wenn euch die Hintergründe
gefallen, die gibt es auf GitHub.
Peepo
White Peepo Happy
Background.
Da habt ihr die ganzen
Bilder. Und es gibt einen Peepo,
die hat der Rackman gebaut.
Kredits.
Es gibt einen
Peepo für jede Tageszeit.
Mittagessen Peepo, Keks
Peepo, Arbeits Peepo,
Energy Booster Peepo.
Um weitere Hintergründe zu machen.
Frühstück
Tee Peepo.
Warmer Kaffee
Peepo und Cornflakes.
Ne, die Dinger hier.
Haben wir das
Ganze noch zum Sonnenaufgang.
Dann träumt er von komischen Sachen.
Und schläft.
Und da geht
die Sonne unter, da geht er Zähneputzen.
Und da guckt er YouTube.
Und da geht er ins Bett.
Ja, gut zu
wissen, gut zu wissen.
Also wenn ihr Ideen habt für noch mehr Backgrounds, Leute.
Dann schickt's
am besten hier oder im Discord an den
Rackman, der macht das.
Dann haben wir noch mehr nice Peepos.
Ich könnte auch noch ein paar mehr gebrauchen, ja.
Immer
nice.
Ja.
Das war mit Fe. Ja, du kannst benutzen, was du
willst. Also, die Bilder sind ja unabhängig
von unserem komischen Set
Backgrounds Skript.
Das musst du ja nicht verwenden.
Man kann die übrigens auch unter Windows verwenden.
Man muss die nicht zwangsläufig mit unserem Change
Skript verwenden.
So sieht's aus.
Ah, ja.
Okay, dann
schauen wir uns mal auf YouTube
um, was wir uns da so geben können.
Warum ich gestern nicht
on war, mal ganz kurz.
Ich hab
eine Runde
Jagged Alliance
oder Jagged Alliance 3 gespielt.
Seit Jahren mal wieder
ein ganz gutes Game in dieser
Serie. Ja, eine kurze
Runde, irgendwie sechs Stunden oder so am Stück.
Aber
es kommt für mich bis jetzt noch
nicht ganz an den zweiten Teil dran.
Der zweite Teil hatte einfach so viele
POG Sachen drinnen.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall mal wieder
ein ganz gutes Taktik, rundenbasiertes
Taktik Game. Ich spiele das
heute immer noch ab und zu, ne?
Dance vs Zombies
ist, es ist so
verkackt worden, ganz ehrlich. Der erste
Teil war richtig gut. Man hätte
einen mega geilen zweiten Teil machen können.
Was haben sie gemacht? Ein Smartphone
Only Game mit Pay2Win
Mechanics. Und das ist schon lange her.
Das heißt,
das kommt auch nicht mehr für eine andere Plattform.
Ja.
Und sie haben jetzt ja versucht, einen dritten
Teil zu machen und das ging halt
komplett in die Hose.
Das ist halt so schlimm.
Also Plants vs Zombies
3, also dieser
Versuch, was sie da versucht haben zu
releasen, ja.
Das sieht schlechter aus
als der erste Teil. Ihr müsst euch das
mal vorstellen.
Das sieht einfach,
das sieht einfach schlechter aus als der erste
Teil.
Okay, es sieht schon mal besser aus
als ganz am Anfang. Aber es hat überhaupt
nicht mehr optisch, überhaupt nicht mehr den
Charme von der Grafik des ersten
Teils.
Ich bin mal gespannt,
wann das rauskommt.
Ich freue mich, dass es einen zweiten Teil gibt.
Alan Wake war jetzt ja,
das war nicht so die große Stärke, das reine
Gameplay. Ich glaube, viele Leute haben
das Spiel nie beendet, weil ihnen
so das Gameplay an sich
nicht gefallen hat.
Aber ich fand die Atmosphäre,
die Story,
das Storytelling und
auch die
Hintergrundgeschichte und alles
drumherum, ich fand Alan Wake extrem nice.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich mag
auch die ganzen Remedy Games.
Was heißt die ganzen?
Viele haben die ja nicht gemacht.
Was haben die für Games gemacht?
Max Payne, Alan Wake,
Dingsbums hier, das mit dem Hobbit,
äh,
Quantum
Break hieß das, glaube ich.
Ähm,
und dann haben sie letztens
dieses, dieses
Control. Ja, Control hieß das.
Control war das einzige Remedy
Game, was ich nicht durchgespielt habe.
Unterschiedlich. Aber Penne
oder Fusli,
Fuseli, wie auch immer
die ausspricht, aber auch schon Spaghetti, alles mögliche.
Ja.
Also ich habe, außer Control, habe ich alle
Remedy Games gespielt.
Und ich fand die, fand die alle ziemlich
gut. Also Control
habe ich nicht durchgespielt.
Warum ist das Stream eigentlich 1080p, 48
FPS? Weil es der
beste Kompromiss ist aus
Bandbreite und
Flüssigkeit.
Manche Leute gehen sogar
so weit und machen den Gameplay in 900p.
48 FPS.
Dann
hast du
quasi für die Einzelnen
noch bessere, also das Bild sieht einfach
dann noch ein bisschen schärfer aus.
Oder weniger,
weniger Kompressionsartefakte.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich finde das eine gute Kombination.
Ja, genau.
Jetzt
im Blastop-Betrieb ist das eh vollkommen
egal. Ich muss übrigens
gerade mal gucken, ob ich...
Ja, ich habe die Bitrate wieder
runtergemacht. Weil,
wenn ich irgendwelche Gaming-Sachen mache, dann
mache ich ja hier hoch auf
7900.
Du-du-du-du-du-du.
So, aber das können wir uns
auch noch auf YouTube jetzt mal zu Gemüte
führen.
I hacked this
firmware and found something concerning.
Ey, wenn das nicht
G-Badass, der Titel.
I made a 32-bit
computer inside...
What?
Das ist mir, glaube ich, zu harte Kost am Anfang.
HTMX
in 100.
Der heilige Retro-Gaming-Kral.
Okay, das können wir uns angucken.
Das davor, ich
habe gar nicht richtig hingehört.
Ja.
Ist es.
Okay. Dann, hören wir uns das
mal an.
Mister.
Ne, alte Spielkonsolen
wie die Wii bestimmt nicht, weil das der Wii-Sound
im Hintergrund war.
Guck mal hier.
Super Nintendo, ja.
Super Nintendo dürfte wahrscheinlich so mit das höchste der
Gefühle sein, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, was das Ding sonst noch kann,
aber viel... Also, der Unterschied
ist... Also, ich kenne das Teil vom Lesen.
Ich habe keins, ja.
Wobei, ich labere
gar nicht. Wahrscheinlich erklärt das direkt im Video.
Ich muss jetzt gar nichts erzählen. Monopol, danke
schön für den Sub.
Und der Gelegenheit,
mal gucken, dass ich nicht wieder die Hälfte übersehen habe.
Ne, habe ich
nicht.
Das Krasse ist, das ist kein normaler Computer.
Oder es ist vielleicht auch gar kein Computer, sondern
ein sogenanntes FPGA.
Größter Unterschied, anders als bei normaler
Emulation soll es viel weniger
Lag geben, also viel weniger
Verzögerungen. Bei normaler Emulation
soll es viel weniger Lag geben,
also viel weniger Verzögerungen
zwischen dem Drücken eines Controller-Buttons
und der Reaktion des Spiels.
Das werde ich gleich ausprobieren, im Vergleich
mit der guten alten Emulation
auf einem Raspi 4. Dazu hatten wir schon mal Videos.
Und ich frage mich selbst, merke ich
den Unterschied? Wir probieren das erstmal mit
Super Mario World aus und ich bin
selbst sehr gespannt, ob sich der ganze
Aufwand mit dem FPGA-Zeug überhaupt
lohnt. Ich glaube, ich
predikte jetzt einfach mal, was da rauskommt.
Ich gehe davon aus, für Leute,
die es pur so nah wie möglich
am Original wollen,
ist diese FPGA-Geschichte nice.
Für alle anderen würde ich
sagen, ist ein Emulator
eine Emulator-Kiste
trotzdem das Bessere.
Einfach, weil du mehr Plattformen
drauf abbilden kannst.
Und wahrscheinlich, weil du schlicht und ergreifend
Features hast drumherum.
Und die Ausgabe auf dem modernen Bildschirm
vielleicht sogar einfacher ist und besser
funktioniert. Wir haben auch noch Pascal am Start.
Der ist quasi ein Pro-Gamer.
So lange es nicht Hector Pascal ist.
Und spielt Fighting Games.
Das ist so jemand, der sehr sensibel auf solche
Sachen reagiert. Mal gucken, ob er das
erkennt, wenn ich es nicht erkenne.
Über das Technische weiß Dennis Bescheid.
Der hat den Mister nämlich schon auf Herz und Nieren getestet
und wird mir das alles erklären.
So, jetzt direkt ausprobieren, ob ich
einen Unterschied merke. Bleibt dran.
Oder Turbo Pascal.
Herzlich Willkommen hier bei
Dieses Video wird
gesponsert von Intel Wipro.
Wenn ihr jetzt denkt, hä, ich kenne Intel
Core, Celeron, Pentium, aber was?
Wipro, ist das nicht
diese Remote Management
Geschichte von Intel?
Oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Das ist Wipro, da kann ich euch helfen.
Wipro ist eine Plattform für Unternehmensrechner.
Okay, nein ist es nicht.
Wie nennt sich das Ding von Intel?
Diese Remote Management Steuerungsgeschichte,
die schon für viele Sicherheitsprobleme
gesorgt hat.
Das heißt glaube ich
Intel Management Engine oder sowas.
Wenn da Intel Wipro draufsteht,
wisst ihr nicht nur, dass da mehr als genug
Rechenleistung drin steckt, sondern auch,
dass ihr die Rechner kaputtet, weil die User beispielsweise
kaputtet.
Erbung Ende. Ich fange jetzt einfach mal an
zu spielen. Also ich weiß wirklich nicht,
welches von den beiden Super Mario Worlds
Raspy ist und was. Okay, links
ist der Mister und rechts ist der
Raspberry Pi. Ich glaube,
im direkten Vergleich erkennt man es
wahrscheinlich ganz gut, dass die Farben
ein bisschen unterschiedlich sind. Ich glaube, da
muss man sich jetzt keine Gedanken
machen. Das liegt wahrscheinlich weder
am emulieren und nicht
am nicht emulieren, sondern am Winkel, wie die Monitore
aufgenommen werden.
Mister, die Controller
haben wir natürlich über Kabel angeschlossen,
damit wir nicht noch zusätzliche Verzögerung einbauen.
Also es fühlt sich extrem
direkt an. Wenn das der Raspy ist,
kann das eigentlich nicht geschlagen werden, weil das
fühlt sich super direkt an.
Also da habe ich irgendwie überhaupt nichts auszusetzen.
Dann probiere ich jetzt mal das zweite
Gerät aus.
Oha. Gut,
das fühlt sich genauso direkt
an.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, ich dachte
jetzt schon wunderbar, es kommt, oha, ich merke sofort
den Lack, aber nein, es fühlt sich genauso direkt an.
In dieser Overworld
Karte, da lackt es aber auch
auf dem Super Nintendo selbst ein bisschen, wenn du drückst.
Das fühlt sich genauso direkt an.
Diese Animation,
diese Aufpixel-Animation, die sah irgendwie
falsch aus. Also ich spüre
zwar keine Latenz, aber irgendwie wirkt das
auf mich eine Art und Weise ruckelig.
Doch, ganz klar.
Ja, nee.
Ich glaube, das habe ich mir nur eingebildet.
Auch das Ruckeln sieht genauso aus.
Ja, ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen,
ich kann dir jetzt nicht sagen, das hat eine Verzögerung,
das hat keine Verzögerung. Ich merke das nicht auf Anhieb.
Was ich jetzt mal probiere, ist, dass ich jetzt
super gleichzeitig bei beiden
Gamepads den X-Knopf zu drücken,
um zu gucken, ob ich das irgendwie erkenne.
Habt ihr eine Empfehlung für einen
SSH-Client für Windows-Multi-Tab-Sessions?
Wie wäre es, wenn du einfach das ganz normale
Windows-Terminal benutzt, weil
Windows hat mittlerweile einen SSH-Client
dabei. Du kannst einfach
das ganz normale Windows-Terminal benutzen,
und dann sagst du ssh-keckel.com
und dann funktioniert
das.
Machst einen neuen
Tab auf. Und noch besser
das Ganze natürlich mit WSL.
Neben das, das ist mittlerweile
bei Windows dabei, kann mehrere
Tabs und SSH
ist auch dabei. Also du brauchst
eigentlich gar nichts Zusätzliches
mehr. Finger weg.
PowerShell selbst sagt, aber um einfach
SSH einzutippen, reicht es ja schon.
Bei beiden Gamepads
den X-Knopf zu drücken, um
zu gucken, ob ich das irgendwie erkennen kann,
dass es da einen Unterschied gibt.
Ich hab keinen Unterschied
gesehen. Ja, doch!
Links war einen Ticken schneller,
wobei es halt auch
einfach sein kann, dass er nicht exakt
synchron gedrückt hat.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass es
da eine Idee früher da war.
Ich würde dazu tendieren zu sagen,
dass das das FPGA ist und das
der Raspi. Ich würde dann jetzt aber mal
an den Profi weitergeben.
Wie fühlt sich das an? Erste Sekunde
fühlt es sich gut an. Hast du schon mal gespielt?
Ich hab das schon 300 Mal durchgespielt.
Deswegen gucke ich gerade so, was sind die Stellen, die man eigentlich
blind spielt. Und klappt
es, wenn ich es blind spiele?
Trotzdem. Und wenn es nicht klappt, dann muss ja eine kleine
Verzögerung sein, weil an mir kann es nie liegen.
Verstehe.
Es fühlt sich richtig an. Allerdings brauche ich
jetzt den Vergleich.
Hör mal auf, Leute, mit
Ober-X-Term. Grausam.
Das haben wir auf der Arbeit. Ich mag
das überhaupt nicht.
Das fühlt sich an wie eine Software von
1998. Der ist schneller.
Der ist direkter. Das hatte ich auch schon gesagt.
Gerade wenn ich hier mich
so ganz schnell hin und her mal bewege,
das fühlt sich nicht an, als würde er irgendwie
hinterherziehen. Aber es ist nicht so,
dass man denkt, wow, was für ein krasser Unterschied.
Das ist komplett spielbar
und ohne Probleme und du kannst
dann deine coolen Tricks machen. Ich glaube, wenn es wirklich
gerade auf Hard kommt, würde ich mir
diesen hier greifen. Ja, ist ja auch
meine These. Okay, dann würde ich jetzt
sagen, dann lass es mal auf Street Fighter 2.
Das ist ja auch so dein...
Ich spiele es gerne. Gut, also dieses
Spiel bringt mir jetzt... Also, wenn ich
das letzte Mal vor ungefähr 300
Jahren gespielt habe, da kann ich...
Das fühlt sich für mich ganz normal an.
Aber ich kann es überhaupt nicht beurteilen.
Also, du gewinnst schon mal damit.
Ich gewinne schon mal. Das ist schon mal gut.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, hätte ich viel besser gewonnen,
wenn ich auf dem Gerät gespielt hätte? Ja, probier es aus.
Ich muss sagen, das fühlt sich schon
einiges knackiger an. Ja?
Ja, ja, das ist wirklich... Ja, aber das
würdest du auch sagen, das ist besser.
Ich würde sagen, dass das nicht nur besser ist,
sondern schon auch definitiv besser.
Ich glaube, ich hatte ein bisschen weniger Leben beim anderen.
Deswegen ist das, glaube ich,
ein Zeichen dafür.
Wir haben unsere Antwort jetzt eingeloggt.
Das ist der FPGA, der Mister.
Okay, es macht anscheinend echt einen Unterschied,
auch wenn es sehr subtil ist,
weil sonst hätten nicht beide richtig gelegen.
Also, es muss wohl schon spürbar sein.
Und wisst ihr, ich glaube,
so richtig spürbar wäre das erst,
wo du es sofort sagen könntest,
wenn du jetzt, keine Ahnung,
zwei, drei Monate oder ein paar Tage,
sagen wir mal, ein paar Tage
hiermit gespielt hast
und dann schiebt dir einer so ein Ding unter.
Dann wirst du wahrscheinlich sofort sagen,
Moment, irgendwas ist heute laggy und stimmt nicht richtig.
Das ist der Raspi.
Also, ich bin mir nicht so sicher,
aber Karl ist sich total sicher.
Und wenn das jetzt nicht der FPGA ist,
dann fällt das Video aus.
Dann weiß ich nicht, warum wir dieses Video machen.
Okay.
Jetzt machen wir den großen Reveal.
Hier hinten ist nämlich extra alles versteckt.
Hier haben wir den Mister FPGA.
Der läuft auf dem.
Habt ihr richtig erkannt.
Und hier ist der Raspi 4.
Direkt habt ihr es schon echt gut beschrieben.
Es ist verzögerungsfrei.
Das kommt super direkt rüber.
Ich muss sagen, ich habe da auch so ein paar Spezialoptionen
noch aktiviert.
Run Ahead heißt eine.
Ach, das ist aktiviert?
Ja, genau. Das habe ich extra aktiviert.
Das wäre mein Joker, den ich jetzt eigentlich aus der Tasche ziehen wollte.
Dass ich sage, ja, okay, aber Raspis und schnellere Rechner
haben ja dieses Run Ahead Feature.
Mir ist es immer so müh aufgefallen,
dass es da noch so ein Ticken direkt da ist.
Aber hier ohne Run Ahead Funktion war es vielleicht auch
nochmal müh verzögert da.
Aber es waren jetzt keine weltengroßen Unterschiede.
Man muss schon sagen, Software Emulation ist heutzutage
sehr, sehr gut und die Hardware Emulation.
Ja, gerade für den Super Nintendo.
Das dürfte ja eines der meist emulierten Konsolen überhaupt sein.
Von dem FPGA und dem Mister Projekt.
Das setzt nochmal eine Schippe oben drauf.
Und wie gesagt, absolute Profis, die schwören da halt drauf.
Und wir haben es jetzt im Test ja auch gesehen.
Das ist halt einfach super direkt.
Ich bin leider jetzt ein bisschen sauer,
weil ich immer gedacht habe, ach, Raspi 4, geil,
kann ich alle alten Spiele noch spielen.
Jetzt muss ich die ganze Zeit daran denken,
wenn ich mit dem Raspi spiele,
ah, es könnte noch besser sein, wenn ich mir so einen blöden Mister kaufe.
Das ist die psychologische Komponente.
Dafür hast du es auf dem Raspberry Pi
sicherlich tausendmal komfortabler,
weil da halt ein richtiges Linux drunter läuft
oder nach dem, worauf man das Ganze laufen lässt.
Du hast mehr Emulatoren zur Auswahl.
Wahrscheinlich auch generell mehr Features.
Das nervt mich jetzt.
Zum Beispiel beim Neo Geo Metal Slug.
Und da sind die Slowdowns
auf dem Original Neo Geo,
also das Spiel überfordert die Hardware ein bisschen
und die Slowdowns sind genau
an den exakt identischen Stellen beim Mister
wie bei der Original-Hardware
und auch bei den ganzen Arcade-Automaten und so.
Also das ist schon wirklich eine
fast hundertprozentige Reproduktion.
Du hast in diesem FPGA
quasi 110.000
logische Einheiten, die du programmieren kannst.
Und es gibt fast 40 Spiele.
Das sieht ein bisschen rudimentär zusammengesteckt aus,
das Ding, oder?
Also ich gehe davon aus,
dass man das nicht selbst bauen muss,
sondern dass man das so geliefert bekommt.
Das sieht ein bisschen zusammengebastelt aus.
10.000
logische Einheiten.
Guck mal, hier hast du so ein komisches Modul drauf.
Was ist denn das für eine Batterie?
Sieht aus, als kommt da eine Batterie rein.
Das hier ist eventuell
Speicher, keine Ahnung.
Das da ist ein
Netzwerkanschluss vermutlich, oder USB.
Nee, das ist USB, das ist Netzwerk.
Die du programmieren kannst.
Und es gibt fast 40
Spielkonsolen, die jetzt schon abgebildet sind.
Oh, doch so viele.
Mega Drive, Neo Geo und so weiter.
Dann gibt es fast 60 Heimcomputer.
Du kannst auch schon 486er heutzutage
emulieren.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
beim Super Nintendo ist da spätestens
Schluss.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass beispielsweise
die Playstation oder der N64
da drauf läuft.
Das ist wahrscheinlich dann doch ein bisschen zu
komplex für das Ding.
Ich hab jetzt Day of the Tentacle da nochmal durchgespielt.
Es war sehr cool.
Lass uns doch mal einmal das Mr. Menü
angucken. Hier hast du die verschiedenen
Cores, die sind sortiert nach Arcade, Computer,
Konsole. Wenn du hier reingehst,
findest du dann hier vom Atari
2600 über ein
Game Boy. Was auch ganz cool ist, die haben
zum Beispiel Game Boy Advance 2 Player.
Das ist, als würdest du dich mit einem Link Kabel
verbinden, aber mit einem Splitscreen.
Es gibt Leute, die haben damals
Pokémon getauscht über Link Kabel.
Super Nintendo natürlich,
Super Game Boy, also es ist vieles
dabei. Aktuell ist Ende der
Fahnenstange Playstation 1.
Der Core ist so groß, dass
er den FPGA komplett...
Ach, PS1 geht doch? Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Voll macht. Jetzt ist aber noch ein deutscher
Entwickler, der heißt FPGA
zum Spaß. Der sitzt gerade
am N64 Core.
Und der ist guter Dinge, dass er das noch hinkriegt.
Aber das würde dann das Ende der Fahnenstange sein.
Dann ist der FPGA einfach ausgelastet.
Und Dreamcast?
Na, Dreamcast auf gar keinen Fall.
Also, mich wundert es schon,
dass PS1 und N64 überhaupt möglich ist.
Oder N64 noch nicht,
aber dass PS1 jetzt schon möglich ist.
Hier, da hinten haben sie
die klassische
RZ-Karre rumstehen.
Wisst ihr, was mich bei diesen Dingern
immer richtig nervt?
Dass du die nicht richtig vorwärts
steuern... äh, nicht richtig...
Nicht richtig vorwärts steuern kannst.
Weil die haben nur Hintenräder,
die steuerbar sind.
Und vorne nicht.
Und manchmal musst du halt auch vorwärts fahren, anstatt rückwärts.
Ich mochte diese Wege nie.
Ich fände die immer richtig eklig.
Zumal das auch alles runterrutscht.
Wir haben teilweise,
der Felix und ich,
auf solchen Kisten,
ja, es mag ein Skill-Issue sein,
aber wir haben
schon hier auf diesen Kisten
30.000 Euro pro Loadbalancer,
also Loadbalancer-Appliance,
drauf rumgefahren.
Vier, fünf Stück aufeinander.
Also wir sind da quasi mit 150.000 Euro
über die Straße gelaufen.
Und der Gehweg war schepp
und auf der einen Seite sind die Dinger immer fast runtergerutscht.
Also ich weiß nicht, warum die uns mit so einer
Schrottkarre hier,
mit so einer Schrott...
Schrottwagen,
so teure Kisten haben rumfahren lassen in Frankfurt.
Aber gut.
Anscheinend nicht verkehrt.
Weil...
ist nie was kaputt gegangen.
Das einzige, was ich je mitbekommen habe,
wo Server runtergefallen sind,
war mal ein DL-380 von
HP.
Der ist doch HP, nicht Dell.
Und der ist nicht einfach runtergefallen.
Der ist runtergefallen und ist einem auf den Fuß gefallen.
Und der war erst mal zwei Wochen dann
außer Gefecht.
Aber wenn ihr so ein...
Das Ding wiegt ja bestimmt voll bestückt mit Festplatten.
Wiegt ja bestimmt
30 Kilo oder so.
Die Dinger sind ja schwer als Fuck.
Und wenn dir das aus Tragehöhe auf den Fuß fällt,
du hast natürlich keine Sicherheitsschuhe an und sowas,
das haut schon einiges
kaputt im Fuß.
Nee, auf keinen Fall.
Also mein Traum ist ja immer noch, was ich irgendwann mal
gerne ausprobieren will, ist,
wie schnell ein Playcenter werden kann
bei vollem Lüfterbetrieb, wenn du es auf ordentlich gelagerte
Rollen stellst.
Ich gebe zu, es ist schwierig
nachzubauen, aber diese Lüfter
haben schon ordentlich Power.
Ja, dann schon auch die großen 32-Bit-Konsolen,
die kriegst du in diesem FPGA
nicht mehr abgebildet.
Kannst du mir noch mal sagen, wie teuer ist denn
das jetzt? Also wenn du wirklich nur
ein Basic-Paket von dem Mista nimmst,
da kriegst du im Endeffekt nur
das FPGA-Board. Da hast du alle
Schnittstellen dran, HDMI, Netzwerk,
MicroSD. Ach, es gibt sogar ein HDMI-Output.
Okay. Ich hätte gedacht,
die haben auch eher so einen Klassiker noch,
so S-Video oder sowas.
Und um es abscalen musst du dich dann
selbst kümmern. Karte und
einen USB-Anschluss. Aber das ist anscheinend nicht so. Dann holst du dir noch
einen USB-Hub, damit du überhaupt Kontrolle anschließen kannst.
Und das FPGA-Board kostet
220 Euro
ungefähr halt. Brauchst noch ein
Netzteil. Also du kommst auf jeden Fall unter
300 Euro in der Minimalausstattung weg.
Wenn du ein bisschen mehr Komfort haben willst,
sprich mehr USB-Schnittstellen,
wenn du einen optischen Tonausgang brauchst,
wenn du einen VGA- oder analogen Bildausgang
brauchst, brauchst du noch Zusatzboards
genau im Gehäuse. Vollausstattung zusammengebaut.
Ja, da bist du dann schon so 600 Euro los.
Ordentlich.
Geh doch mal in Super Nintendo.
Für 600 Euro kannst du dir einen richtig schnellen
Mini-PC kaufen schon. Aber gut,
der ist dann halt nicht
so exakt,
wenn man alte
Konsolen spielen will, wie das Ding.
Dafür hast du halt viel mehr Möglichkeiten.
Nintendo rein.
Jetzt liegt da den Core,
dass er jetzt quasi dem FPGA sagt,
du bist jetzt ein Super Nintendo.
Dann kann man die Spiele hier auswählen.
Das Menü ist, man sieht es, schwarz-weiß.
Es ist absolut schlicht bis hässlich.
Aber zum Auswählen von Spielen reicht es aus.
Es gibt ja zum Beispiel
in der Retro-Art-Community
sowas wie Retro Achievements,
dass man für alte Spiele Achievements bekommt.
Ich hab mir einen Mini-PC was gebastelt.
Ich hab auch so
Retro Achievements und sowas da drin.
Aber
das ist dann halt nicht so exakt
detailgetreu
wie der Mister,
wenn es um Super Nintendo und sowas geht.
Also wenn man da Wert drauf legt,
dass es exakt so ist wie
auf der Original-Hardware alles,
so wenig wie möglich
lag,
ist das vielleicht echt noch
eine Überlegung wert.
Eng gebaut?
Was kann ich jetzt noch zusätzlich machen,
was ich mit der normalen Konsole nicht machen könnte?
Also du könntest jetzt hier quasi
noch ein paar Videofilter
dazuschalten als Beispiel.
Also man kann Scanline-Filter
aktivieren. Das simuliert dann diesen
zeilenartigen Bildaufbau von
diesen alten Röhrenfernseher.
Da gibt es zum Beispiel auch Core-Specific welche.
Die sind dann auf das NES ausgelegt.
Zum Beispiel Super Nintendo Scanlines.
Zack.
Sieht aus wie auf einem Röhrenfernseher.
Wenn ich das jetzt anmache, dann sieht man gleich,
dass hier dieser typische Effekt von einem
Röhrenmonitor dann abgebildet wird.
Das ist super authentisch aus.
Du kannst auch ein Fünffach-Scaling machen,
nennt sich das. Also dann skaliert der die alte
Auflösung von 320x216
1080p hoch,
Full HD. Dann hast du quasi eine pixelperfekte
Skalierung. Ich würde aber jetzt
aus dem Gefühl sagen, dass das
mehr aussieht wie ein Röhrenfernseher.
Da baut er jetzt hier noch Scanlines ein.
Da ist halt noch so ein bisschen mehr.
Sieht noch ein bisschen echter aus sozusagen.
Du kannst auch einen WLAN-Dongle an den Nister
hängen. Dann bist du im Internet und dann kannst du dir
über... Ach, ich dachte es hat einen RJ45-Stecker
hinten gehabt. Update-Skripte.
Ganz simpel. Dann die neuen
Cores holen oder neue Videofilter oder so.
Das ist alles mehr oder weniger automatisiert.
Ich benutze ehrlich gesagt auf dem
Raspi benutze ich halt wirklich auch so Funktionen
wie Savegames. Also dass ich abspeichere,
obwohl es die Funktionen im Spiel eigentlich gibt
und zurückspulen. Das hat ja sogar...
Die haben doch auf dem Nister sicherlich
noch eine normale CPU drauf, wo irgendein
Mini-Linux oder so läuft.
Allein schon für das On-Screen-Menü
und für Update-Funktionalität
und sowas.
Was ist...
Das hat der Nister wahrscheinlich auch nicht, ne?
Also der Nister ist, sagen wir mal so, auf Authentizität
getrieben. Ja, so Sachen wie Savegames
sind schon enorm praktisch.
Wenn man alte Games spielt.
Wenn ich mir überlege, damals musstest
du noch zu irgendeinem Speicherpunkt rennen.
So was weiß ich. Die Mutter kommt rein und sagt hier
oh, wir müssen jetzt unbedingt los. Dann musst du erst mal
zurück ins nächste Dorf speichern und sowas.
Ja.
Das war damals halt...
doof. Und das ist heute
im Prinzip immer noch doof. So Sachen wie Savegames
sind einfach praktisch.
Dass das Erlebnis genauso wie früher ist
und das ist in dem Bereich natürlich ein Riesen-Nachteil.
Weil, klar, wenn du jetzt
ein Super-Nintendo spielst...
An der Stelle, wo früher das Super-Nintendo speichern konnte
auf der Batterie im Spielmodul
kannst du auch speichern.
Aber es gibt nur eine Handvoll Cores,
die diese Save-States bieten.
Also dass du zu jedem Zeitpunkt speichern kannst.
Der NES-Core kann das, der Playstation-1-Core kann das.
Die Cores, die das nicht können,
die werden es wahrscheinlich auch niemals können,
weil das extrem aufwendig ist.
Also im Grunde muss der Core von Grund auf
mit Save-State im Hinterkopf entwickelt werden,
weil sonst ist es so komplex, dass du es nicht hinkriegst.
Und Rückspulfunktionen gab es früher
im Kinderzimmer nicht und gibt es bei Mister
dann auch nicht. Kleiner Nachteil.
Aber du kannst zum Beispiel Cheats aktivieren.
Fast für jedes Spiel füllst du Cheats.
Dann kannst du dich unbesiegbar machen oder du machst dir
99 Leben bei Mario oder was weiß ich.
Und hier habe ich halt, ich meine,
das ist halt schon ein großer Unterschied.
Also wenn ich hier jetzt in das Menü reingehe,
dann habe ich einen Packshot zu jedem Spiel.
Ich habe ein Video zu jedem Spiel.
Punkto Optik schlägt der Raspi
das natürlich um.
Ja, mein Fazit.
Der große Vorteil ist einfach
nahezu verzögerungsfrei.
Und den Unterschied merkt sogar ich,
der absolut kein Programmer ist.
Aber wenn man natürlich so Spiele spielt wie Pokémon,
dann muss man sich so ein Ding nicht anschaffen,
weil ansonsten hat der Mister
gegenüber so einem Raspi halt viele Nachteile.
Deutlich teurer, ab 300 Euro
bis 600 Euro. Ja gut, Raspberry Pi
sind halt auch leider
unsinnig teuer. Wobei ich habe gehört,
Chatgy, dass es
mittlerweile angeblich mit dem Lieferengpass
nicht mehr ganz so schlimm ist. Wir müssen gleich mal
gucken. Viele Cores haben keine Safe Games.
Er hat keine Retro Achievements.
Das Menü ist deutlich hässlicher
und deutlich kummeliger
als beim Raspi. Der Raspi 4
im Vergleich hat Vorteile.
Günstig, super flexibel, kann zum Beispiel
auch Dreamcast emulieren. Das kann
das FPGA System nicht. Man kann es
rückspulen, man hat Safe Games.
Der Nachteil ist allerdings, man hat
einen leichten Lag, vielleicht 5 Frames
oder so. Den hat man bei dem FPGA System
nicht. Also, wenn man jetzt mal so eine Empfehlung
aussprechen soll, geht nicht. Ist eine total
individuelle Sache. Das heißt, wenn es euch darum
geht, absolut das Originalsystem
nachzubilden und euch wirklich 2 Frames
latent... Woher hat jemand
eine Idee, woher der Lag kommt
beim Emulieren?
Ich persönlich vermute ja über den
USB-Input, oder?
Nicht von der Emulation selbst.
Also, ich gehe einfach
mal davon aus, dass eine alte Konsole
direkt den Input pollen konnte,
jeden Frame.
Was ein
Emulator, was
auf einem aktuellen Betriebssystem läuft, halt
nicht machen kann.
Daher vermute ich mal,
dass es daher kommt. Warum?
Wissen
tue ich es nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber du hast halt keinen direkten Zugriff
auf irgendwelche
Controller-States und sowas
von einem Emulator.
Weil das
aktuelle Betriebssysteme halt einfach
nicht erlauben. Also, ich denke
mal, da kommt das her nicht.
Das liegt nicht am Emulator selbst.
Der Emulator kann schlicht und ergreifend
halt einfach nicht jeden Frame
den Input abfragen.
Und dann
muss, sobald der
Input da ist, kann er da auch
gesagt werden, okay, wie muss ich
das Game jetzt verhalten?
Und dementsprechend, dann ergibt
das auch Sinn mit diesem
Ahead of
Time, was die eben erzählt haben.
Die rechnen einfach Frames
im Voraus für
wenn der Spieler jetzt gedrückt hätte.
Und dann können sie quasi
direkt da drauf springen, sobald der Input
vorliegt. Also, ich gehe
davon aus, dass es eben an modernen
Betriebssystemen und
ja, den
nicht möglichen direkten Zugriff auf
Controller-Inputs
zusammenhängt.
Es liegt nicht direkt am Emulator
selbst, weil es emulieren würde.
Den hat man bei dem MP3. Rate ich jetzt mal.
Hab mich damit nicht weiter beschäftigt.
Ja, das ist dem nicht. Also, wenn
man jetzt mal so eine Empfehlung aussprechen soll,
ist es eine total individuelle Sache.
Das heißt, wenn es euch darum geht, absolut
das Originalsystem nachzubilden und euch
wirklich zwei Frames Latenz
auffallen und ihr solche Spiele spielt,
bei denen das auch eine Rolle spielt, dann solltet ihr euch
den Mister etwas genauer angucken.
Bei allen anderen, denen es um Komfort geht
und solche Geschichten. Dann nehmt kein
Raspberry Pi, sondern nehmt einen Mini-PC,
wenn ihr ein bisschen mehr Kohle ausgeben wollt.
Wenn ihr mit diesen zwei Frames leben könnt,
dann seid ihr mit dem Raspi 4
oder dem alten, gebraucht, Thin Client
seid ihr besser mit. Oder einem ordentlich
modernen Mini-PC, weil dann kannst du auch
so Sachen wie Wii Upscaled spielen.
Ja, wie seht ihr das? Seid ihr da
empfindlich, was Latenz angeht? Merkt ihr das?
Dann schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare und natürlich
abonnieren. Tschüss.
Ja, so sieht's
aus. Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Und jetzt, komm, jetzt gucken wir
uns das Video von Firechip an.
Wenn irgendjemand vorhin gemeint hat,
hier, guck mal, HTMX.
Da gibt's auch ein Video von
Firechip. Lasst uns das mal schnell zu Gemüte führen.
Geht auch nur 2 Minuten 26.
Okay, ein neues
JavaScript-Framework, das hat die Welt gebraucht.
Yeah!
Was?
Ah, T-O-R.
Alles klar.
Aber, Moment, das ist quasi
Server-Side-Rendering
in Kombination
mit kleinen Dings.
Was bin ich da sehend
überhaupt? Der rendert das dann
auf dem Server, schickt's zurück und dann wird's
replaced. Aber warum sollte ich
das nicht mit
Client-Side-JavaScript machen? Ist das nicht sinniger?
Vor allem, wie müsste ich die Server-Seite
aufbauen, dass das funktioniert?
Man weiß es nicht. Wir werden's gleich sehen.
...
Das ist Firechip, ja.
Ähm.
Ach so, jetzt habe ich das kapiert.
Der ruft mich jetzt an.
Okay.
Ja.
Aber wenn du noch ein bisschen was Älteres hast, was du fit machen willst, vielleicht
was sich ein bisschen schneller anfühlen soll, ist das doch gut.
Wobei, was ich halt nicht verstehe ist, warum man komplett, wenn man eine neue Anwendung
baut, es damit machen sollte.
... to replace this element with the HTML in the response.
When swapping though, we don't only have the option to replace the outer HTML, but we
could also append or prepend the response to the existing UI.
Or the hx-target attribute allows us to move the UI to a completely different element.
It finds that element with a CSS selector, but has additional syntax like next and closest,
allowing you to easily find the proper element without a bunch of custom IDs.
You might also use htmx-indicator to show a loading spinner, and write a CSS transition
animation for the incoming element.
Behind the scenes, htmx has an extensive event system that you can tap into by listening
to custom events with JavaScript.
And if you want to run your own client-side JavaScript, the hx-on attribute allows you
to bind a JavaScript function to any element.
And that's all it takes to build a highly polished, full-stack HTML application on the
information superhighway.
This has been htmx in 100 seconds.
Do love it or do hate, let me know in the comments.
Thanks for watching, and I will see you in the next one.
Ich kann kein Deutsch, ich bin Englisch.
No worries, I'm English expert.
And yes, this was a Fireship video.
JavaScript nutzen ohne JavaScript nutzen müssen.
Ja, anscheinend.
Ich verstehe es auch nicht genau, was man damit machen soll.
Was auch immer.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid, was htmx ist.
Eine Sache, wo ich jetzt aktuell nicht wüsste, wozu ich sie brauche, und auch nicht ganz
sicher bin, welche Probleme sie löst.
Aber wenn man sie mal braucht, dann ist sie da, okay?
Ja, nee, so genau habe ich es jetzt auch nicht gecheckt, warum man das braucht, man weiß
es nicht.
Alter, ich will kein Chat-GPT-Video gucken, YouTube, please.
Beschleunigte Entwicklung, ja, aber ja, eigentlich nicht, oder?
Wenn du was Neues anfängst, dann kannst du auch einfach Svelte, React, Vue oder sonst
was benutzen, und dann hast du noch mehr Möglichkeiten.
Da kannst du es wirklich auch kleinzeitig machen, ohne jedes Mal die neue Seite zu pollen.
Also ich hätte jetzt gesagt, es ist eher was, um etwas ältere Anwendungen zu beschleunigen.
So richtig gecheckt habe ich es nicht.
Welchen Bluetooth-Adapter könnt ihr empfehlen, wenn ich einen Xiaomi-Blinksthermometer mit
dem was...
Moment, welche ist denn das?
Das da!
Tja, excellent.
Also, das Erste, was du mit dem Ding machen solltest, ist Custom-Firmware draufflashen.
Hast du das Teil hier?
Genau das?
Das habe ich nämlich auch ein paar von.
Die will ich erst kaufen.
Also, es reicht jeder x-beliebige Bluetooth-Adapter.
Ich glaube, ich überlege gerade, wie ich den Empfang mache.
Ah, ich mache den Empfang mit einem ESP32, der bei mir im Bad hängt.
Aber das ist nicht schlimm, weil es gibt ja mittlerweile Bluetooth-Proxys für Home-Assistant.
Du kannst, also entweder machst du einen Bluetooth-Adapter, also einen Bluetooth-Adapter brauchst du auf
jeden Fall an deinem Home-Assistant dran, aber wenn die Reichweite nicht reicht, kannst
du ESP32, kannst du Bluetooth-Proxys benutzen.
Warning.
Also, da kannst du ESP32 zum Verlängern von Bluetooth-Verbindungen benutzen, wenn es nicht
reicht.
Es ist egal, du kannst dir irgendeinen Bluetooth-Adapter kaufen.
Du solltest aber unbedingt, du solltest aber unbedingt Custom-Firmware installieren auf
den Dingern.
Es gibt ein paar Forks hiervon.
Ihm hatte ich mal ein paar Thermometer geschickt zum Basteln und Ausprobieren, aber es gibt
noch ein paar Forks davon.
Musst du dir mal angucken.
Es ist sehr sinnvoll, Custom-Firmware drauf zu installieren in dem Fall und es ist auch
sehr einfach.
Du kannst es direkt über einen Browser machen von einem Rechner, der Bluetooth hat, also
am besten von deiner Windows-Kiste aus.
Unter DINUX im Raspberry Pi gibt es Probleme mit dem Bluetooth-Stack im Browser.
Es gibt so eine Flash-Seite hier, da gehst du hin und dann kannst du hier Bluetooth scannen
über einen Browser und flashen.
Der Vorteil ist, du kannst da jede Menge Sachen einstellen an diesen Thermometern, zum Beispiel
in welchem Intervall die Sensoren abfragen und in welchem Intervall die Daten rausschicken,
weil das normale Thermometer fragt alle paar Sekunden ab und verschickt glaube ich sogar
auch alle zwei Sekunden den neuen Stand.
Alle zwei Sekunden verbraucht halt extrem viel Batterie.
Ich habe es hochgestellt, dass er nur alle 15 Minuten verschickt und ich habe das erste
Moment, ich gucke mal nach Leute, ich sage euch, wann ich das erste gekauft habe und
das ist jetzt fast leer.
Das ist jetzt bei 4 Prozent.
5.
April 2021 habe ich das erste gekauft.
Das hält noch ein bisschen, sagen wir mal, das hält weit über zwei Jahre, so eine kleine
Batterie da drin und die hält aber auch nur so lange, weil ich es eben hochgedreht habe
auf 15 Minuten.
Also alle 15, ich warte jetzt mal, bis die wirklich leer geht, ja, also ich denke mal,
dass es durchaus, oder je nachdem, wenn du es noch ein bisschen besser tunst, meine
Firmware, die ich drauf geflasht habe, war auch nicht die allerneueste im Vergleich zu
dem, was es heute gibt.
Vielleicht gibt es ja noch ein paar Optimierungen, also zwei bis zweieinhalb Jahre, eher zweieinhalb
Jahre hält die Batterie, wenn du das angepasst hast und dann lohnt sich das.
Ich finde in Originalausführungen lohnt sich es gar nicht so sehr, dann brauchst du alle
dreiviertel Jahr eine neue Batterie, das ist kacke, da musst du dann fast zweimal im
Jahr durchs Haus rennen, aber zweieinhalb Jahre, sagen wir mal, knapp zweieinhalb Jahre
ist schon nice.
Ich muss mal gucken, Leute, ob wir es schaffen, ob wir heute Abend noch ein bisschen flashen
im Stream, weil ich muss heute eigentlich noch ein paar Sachen machen und theoretisch
sogar noch ein Video aufnehmen, falls wir das heute hinbekommen.
Erinnert euch noch daran, dass ich letztens ein bisschen was erzählt habe, so was ich
hier an komischen Aktionen von europäischen E-Sport-Organisationen die letzten Jahre über
immer mitbekommen habe?
Wir haben uns jetzt dazu entschieden, da doch mal öffentlich ein Video zuzumachen, also
mit einem, der es aus erster Hand berichten kann, aber wahrscheinlich werden wir keinen
Namen sagen, aber bloß, was da für eine Scheiße abläuft.
Ich meine, ich mache zwar jetzt relativ wenig noch E-Sport-Gaming-bezogenen Content, aber
ich gucke halt selbst schon lange und es gibt ein paar Sachen, da muss man einfach
öffentlich mal was zu sagen, dass gerade auch neue Spieler wissen, auf was sie sich
da für einen Shit einlassen.
AliExpress liefert nicht nach Österreich?
Du musst mal gucken, AliExpress hat ja tausend verschiedene Shops, es gibt ja nicht AliExpress
als Shop.
AliExpress ist ja eher ein Marketplace, du musst einfach mal gucken, ob es andere Anbieter
gibt, die nach Österreich liefern.
Ja, das lohnt sich übrigens auch tatsächlich nur, wenn man die besonders günstig bei AliExpress
kaufen kann.
Ich hatte ja auch mal so ein 10er-Pack bestellt bei AliExpress für ein abgelohntes Ei pro
Thermostat, dann lohnt sich das.
Leute, heute gibt es, ratet mal, was es zu essen gibt heute.
Reis?
Nein.
Kein Reis.
Auch nicht.
Suppe?
Leute.
Entweder gebatet ihr mich jetzt oder ihr wisst es wirklich nicht.
Nudeln mit Lachs?
Nein, auch nicht.
Skippt Spaghetti mit Tomatensauce, weil die von gestern noch übrig ist.
Aber ich habe gedacht, ich gebate euch mal, weil die meisten ja immer der Meinung sind,
ich futtere nur noch Nudeln und Lachs.
Tdili, dankeschön für den Sub.
Schnitzel?
Oh, Schnitzel, ich habe letztens mega nice was gefuttert und zwar, passt mal auf, mal
schauen, Leute, wir tricksen Twitter jetzt aus.
Wir machen jetzt Twitter-Gebate.
Kann man Twitter-Image-Links aufmachen?
Ha, das funktioniert.
Gebated Twitter.
Gebated.
Genau, also letztens mega nice gefuttert.
Ab und zu, paar mal im Jahr kann man sich sowas gönnen, auch wenn Essengehen extrem
teuer geworden ist.
Ja, Lamm, Rind und Schwein, glaube ich, wenn ich das jetzt richtig aus dem Links sehe und
Porras Bratkartoffeln, hat mega geschmeckt, aber ist teuer geworden.
Richtig teuer.
Ich würde gern Temperaturen auf meinem Balkon messen, Batterie und Bluetooth, könnt ihr
mir da was empfehlen?
Ja, nämlich genau das, was Tdili vor 5 Minuten im Stream gepostet hat, das Ding.
Aber nur, wenn du ein bisschen basteln möchtest, wenn du nicht basteln möchtest, gibt es andere
Varianten.
Wenn du basteln möchtest, finde ich das preis-leistungs-mäßig mit Abstand das Beste.
Basteln heißt, du kaufst dir die Dinge am besten bei AliExpress, weil bei AliExpress
kriegst du die für unter 9 Euro das Stück, zumindest gab es das mal, gucken wir mal kurz.
AliExpress, die nennen das die Amis eigentlich, AliExpress.
Thermometer, ja, die Dinger.
Okay, es ist ein bisschen teurer geworden, hier gibt es auch eins für 1,28 Euro, aber
das ist AliExpress, CheapAid, das willst du haben, 7,68 Euro, sehr schön.
Ja, dann kaufst du dir gleich ein 10er Pack, 10er Pack, hier, 10er Pack 39 Euro, alter
39 durch 10, das muss man, 3 Head, alter, 39 durch 10, was könnte das wohl sein?
So, aber das ist halt enorm billig dann, guck mal, kannst du das Komma hier einfach verschieben,
das ist enorm billig das Stück.
Für den Außenbereich, ne, für den Außenbereich ist es nicht gut, aber willst du den Außenbereich
wirklich im Regen, oder ist es unter einem Dach, solange es unter einem Dach hängt,
dann ist es vollkommen in Ordnung, ne, war ich nicht, auf dem Balkon, da ist doch ein
Dach drüber, das ist gar kein Ding, das hängst du einfach an die Wand, wenn du es natürlich
ins Freie hängen willst, wo wirklich direkter Wasser, Wassereinstrahlung, Regeneinstrahlung,
Sonneneinstrahlung und alles Hagel und so drauf, dann ist das nichts, aber wenn du es
auf dem Balkon hängst, da ist es ja meistens unter dem Dach, dann ist es vollkommen in
Ordnung.
Ja, du musst es aber flashen mit Custom-Firmware und die, das Intervall, wie das die Daten
sendet etwas runterstellen, da kommst du auf knapp zweieinhalb Jahre mit so einer Mini-Batterie,
das ist das günstigste und beste Thermometer, also Luftfeuchtigkeiten-Thermometer, in der
Kombination, was ich mir denken kann.
Es hält ewig mit einer Knopfzellen-Batterie und es ist billig als Fuck und du brauchst
halt irgendeinen Stick, irgendeinen Bluetooth-Stick zum Empfangen.
Name kurz hier, da kannst du Aliexpress, da, diese Dinger, musst halt gucken, dass du irgendwie
eins der findest, wo es billiger ist.
Und das ist das, was ich meinte, mit Aliexpress, das gibt halt verschiedenste, guck mal mal,
Österreich, Austria, Sprache österreichisch, gibt es nicht, wie deutsch, was ist das,
wollt ihr mich veräppeln, das ist doch kein deutsch.
Die liefern, die liefern nicht nach Österreich, guck mal mal die an, die liefern auch nicht
nach Österreich, warum liefern die alle nicht nach Österreich, was ist das, was ist da los,
warum liefern die nicht nach Österreich, Strom noch schneller machen, Quatsch, hab
genug RAM, wir müssen nix noch schneller machen, so, kein Versand nach Österreich,
kein Versand nach Österreich, was ist denn da los, warum schicken die alle nicht nach
Österreich, was machen die Österreicher da wieder für komische Dinger, warum verschickt
Aliexpress nicht nach Österreich, hä, okay, alles klar, wusste ich gar nicht, hängt alles
beim Zoll, ja, aber das ist doch innerhalb der EU, wird das doch verschickt, Aliexpress
schickt doch erst nach Spanien oder Niederlande oder Frankreich oder so und von dort dann weiter,
also es hängt auch nicht im Zoll, ich habe noch nicht einmal was im Zoll hängen gehabt von
Aliexpress, weil das alles innerhalb der EU ist, aber gut, vielleicht machen die Ösis da irgendwelche
komischen Dinger, weiß ich nicht. Wenn was nicht ankommt bei Aliexpress, machst du bei Aliexpress
direkt einen Problemlösungsfall auf und du hast, also Insta ist übertrieben, du hast ratzfatz dein
Geld wieder, also ich muss sagen, ich habe mit Aliexpress echt nur gute Erfahrungen gemacht,
die haben noch nicht mal drauf gewartet, bis der Hersteller das überhaupt, also die haben den
Hersteller nicht mal rausreden lassen, ich habe zwei Tage nicht geantwortet, also gingen sie davon
aus, ich war nicht zufrieden, hab Geld zurückbekommen, da war vor ein paar Monaten mal was,
okay. Was ist der Unterschied zwischen flashen und installieren? Ah, das ist jetzt ein bisschen
so eine esoterische Frage, aber ich würde sagen, flashen heißt halt, du tauschst die Firmware auf
einem Speicher, Flash-Speicher-Chip aus, von der das Gerät bootet und installieren ist, du hast ein
Betriebssystem, was läuft und installierst halt quasi, du tauschst nicht das Betriebssystem und
alles komplett aus, sondern du installierst halt was zusätzlich, was du dann ausführen kannst. Ja,
ist ein bisschen so eine philosophische Frage, wie man das untereinander abgrenzt. Aber mit
flashen ist eigentlich immer gemeint, man tauscht eben die Software, die auf einem Flash-Speicher
von irgendeinem Controller ist, aus gegen was eigenes. Ich könnte auch sagen, ich installiere
das da drauf, aber mit flashen weiß jeder, was gemeint ist. Das Milf-Fahrzeug getestet? Nee,
das ist aber angekommen. Ich habe es schon auseinandergebaut und festgestellt, da ist ein
ESP-8266 noch drin. OTA-Flashen scheinen nicht richtig zu funktionieren, vielleicht habe ich es
auch einfach nicht oft genug ausprobiert. Aber ich habe Debug-Pins, das heißt, wir sollten es von
Hand flashen können. Solange ich nicht GPIO-0 auf Crowns legen muss, dass es flashbar wird,
weil das ist sehr, sehr klein alles. Also wenn ich Zeit habe, probiere ich es heute aus,
heute Abend können wir es zusammen ausprobieren. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das das hinhaut.
So sieht es aus. Ja, ist es auch. Ich mag MongoDB überhaupt nicht. Haben wir MongoDB-Fans hier,
Leute? MongoDB war ultra gehypt, aber es ist die letzten Jahre, oder schon einige Jahre jetzt,
nicht einfach nur die letzten Jahre, bestimmt die letzten fünf Jahre über, schon recht still
um MongoDB geworden. Ich glaube, das wird benutzt immer noch und es ist halt angekommen mittlerweile,
aber so diesen Hauch des, das Beste ever hat es nicht mehr. Also wenn du mich fragst,
wenn ich, welche Datenbank ich verwenden würde, standardmäßig, dann ist es nicht MongoDB. Wenn
ich, wenn mich jemand fragen würde, Max, wir wissen noch nicht so genau, was wir machen wollen
hundertprozentig und wie wir das aufbauen, welche Datenbank würdest du empfehlen, dann würde ich
sagen, immer Postgres. Ja, weil mit Postgres kannst du nahezu alles machen, was du machen
willst, auch Time-Series-Datenbanken, auch Key-Value-Stores, aber halt in manchen Spezialfällen
nicht so performant, wie das jetzt in einer speziellen optimierten Datenbank dafür wäre.
Also mal angenommen, du willst wirklich alles schemalos, reine String-Key-Value-Geschichte
oder so speichern, kannst du das in Postgres machen, auch relativ gut, gibt es ja mittlerweile
Extensions für, dass das richtig gut funktioniert, aber einen Ticken besser dürftest du performant
technisch wahrscheinlich dann immer noch mit MongoDB oder ja den tausend anderen NoSQL-Dingern
sein. Aber wenn du flexibel sein willst, würde ich einfach immer Postgres verwenden. Postgres
ist einfach mega-pock, du kannst in Postgres zum Beispiel, nur mal so zum Vergleich, du
kannst in Postgres ganz klassische, relationales Datenbank-Gedöns machen, ganz normales SQL
oder SQL, wie es manche Leute nennen, die ich jetzt einmal weird-champen muss, also
kannst du in Postgres ganz normale SQL-Abfragen machen, so wie man das kennt und so wie man
das vielleicht auch kann und ganz alles klassisch in Postgres. Dann kannst du in Postgres Fulltext-Search
machen, ohne dass du zusätzliche Sachen wie Elasticsearch oder so ein Gedöns machen musst,
ja direkt eingebaut, was übrigens SQLite sogar auch kann, wenn auch nicht so gut. Du kannst
Fulltext-Search machen, kannst ein Fulltext-Search-Index aufbauen in Postgres, du kannst zusätzlich zu
diesem Fulltext-Search in Postgres auch noch, das nennt sich Trigramm-Search machen, da
muss man jetzt nicht wissen, was es ist, aber man kann mit Trigramm-Search Substrings suchen,
das geht ja mit reiner Fulltext-Search nicht. Reiner Fulltext-Search geht auf komplette
Wörter, die durch bestimmte Trennzeichen, meistens Leerzeichen, Kommas und so getrennt
sind. Trigramm-Search indiziert das Ganze quasi immer in Dreierbuchstabenblöcken,
du kannst Substring-Search machen, was extrem pock ist, wenn du so Autocomplete-Felder machen
willst. Also wenn du sowas hier bauen willst, so Autocomplete-Felder, dann ist das einfach
mega nice und super schnell. Da kommst du mit Fulltext-Search nicht sonderlich weit. Das
kannst du in Postgres machen, du kannst in Postgres Timeseries-Datenbank, hier Postgres Time Scale
Extension, kannst du in Postgres machen und du kannst auch noch so Sachen machen wie,
ah ne, das ist jetzt nur für .NET, Transactional Event Store und du kannst dann auch in Postgres
auch noch relativ gut Postgres Key Value Store machen, gibt es extra Sachen für und Postgres
hat sogar eingebauten JSON-Support, da kannst du sogar JSON-Objekte queren in Postgres. Guck,
kannst du solche Abfragen machen. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das nicht auch andere Datenbanken
können, aber ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass die Kombination aus diesen ganzen Sachen relativ
einzigartig für Postgres ist, beziehungsweise auch in der Verbreitung, der Support will ich
jetzt nicht nennen, aber durch die Verbreitung halt auch dem Know-How, ja, also das ist schon
ziemlich einzigartig. Ich hab keine Ahnung von SQL. Ich hab das jetzt so erzählt, als bin ich der
Wahnsinns-Datenbank-Checker oder so, aber das stimmt nicht. Ich hab keine Ahnung von Datenbanken
und SQL. Das ist tatsächlich einer der Punkte in der IT, wo ich sagen muss, wo ich von Anfang an
immer sagen muss, wenn es darum geht, habe ich keinen Plan. Ich kenne mich recht breit in vielen
Gebieten aus und ich habe natürlich auch so meine Spezialgeschichten, aber Datenbanken ist echt
nix davon. Datenbanken habe ich keine Ahnung. Habe ich bis jetzt immer einen großen Bogen drum
gemacht und habe ich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht vor mich da, ich meine, ich kann mich mit einer
Postgres-Datenbank verbinden und da irgendwie Drop Database machen, ja, das kriege ich hin,
aber SQL-Abfragen schreiben von Hand kriege ich nicht gescheit gebacken und sonstige Datenbank-Sachen
kriege ich auch nicht gebacken. Also das ist wirklich nicht mein Fachgebiet, aber wie gesagt,
man muss ja auch nicht alles können. So, was können wir uns denn noch so angucken?
I made a 32-bit computer inside Terraria. Okay, jetzt geht's los. Jetzt wird's high IQ,
Leute. Hat der Whooploss schon die Influx-DB-Cloud-Geschichte? Nee, was ist damit? News
checken. Influx-DB-Cloud, äh, konnte man hier nicht mal auf News klicken? Bin ich jetzt verwirrt? Hä?
Leute, gab es da nicht immer einen News-Button normalerweise bei Google? Was ist denn das hier
jetzt? Das ist neu. So ein Shit, Alter. Was ist das hier? Was haben sie sich da wieder ausgedacht?
Was, Influx-Data-Import... Was meinst du? Die sind nicht einfach zu debuggen. Ja, da habe ich auch
keinen Plan von. Ich weiß, was es ist, aber ich habe keine Ahnung davon. Was meinst du mit der
Influx-DB-Cloud-Geschichte? Was da, was da gewesen ist? Ah, mich juckt's am Bein, Alter. Da hat mich
irgendeine Mücke gestochen. Die haben ein paar Regionen gelöscht. Anscheinend waren da nicht
alle informiert und dann waren die Daten weg. Ja, ich denke, man geht gerade in die Cloud, weil
die Cloud-Anbieter das doch alles immer besser wissen und besser können, als man das selbst hier
könnte. Das ist eines der Argumente, die ich für Cloud immer höre. Aber im Prinzip stimmt das
natürlich schon, ja. Also, was Microsoft, Google und Amazon da an Ressourcen und Know-How in ihre
Cloud-Plattformen stecken, das kannst du nicht einfach mal so replizieren alleine mit 4-5-Mann-Team
und so. Das ist schon was dran, dass die das in der Regel doch besser wissen, wie man das betreibt.
Was aber nicht automatisch heißt, dass es für alles die beste Idee ist, das da hinzupacken.
All data deleted. A warning for those using Influx-Cloud-DB. Wo läuft denn Influx? AWS?
Oder haben die selbst irgendwelche Rechenzentren? Europe West 1 klingt irgendwie sehr nach Google.
Warum löschen die einfach random Regionen? Das ist ja Fail, Alter. Okay, die haben Regionen gelöscht,
weil sie sich wahrscheinlich nicht mehr rentiert haben oder was auch immer. Und die haben den Leuten
einfach nicht Bescheid gesagt, dass sie das jetzt löschen. Die haben die Nutzer benachrichtigt, aber
sind manchmal nicht angekommen. Okay, vielleicht reden sie sich auch raus und haben nie welche
verschickt. Aber ganz ehrlich, wenn ich Regionen lösche, sodass danach nicht irgendwie gesagt wird,
okay, ihr müsst jetzt die Region ändern. Vielleicht ist es Latency-mäßig nicht okay, aber dann müsst ihr
halt woanders mitgehen. Einfach löschen. Das ist halt echt Fail. Also, das ist halt wirklich Fail.
Und ein weiterer Grund für, warum man nicht immer blind Sachen in die Cloud migrieren sollte. Habe BWL
studiert und arbeite seit zwei Jahren im IT-Controlling. Oh je, MonkaS, Alter. Oder um nicht zu sagen. Aber gut,
jeder worauf er Bock hat. Deshalb etwas IT-Luft geschnuppert und seit dem Anfang des Jahres
versuche ich mich etwas mit dem Programmieren zu beschäftigen. Anfang Free Bootcamp, die Basics von
die sind, glaube ich, ganz okay. Die haben doch auch einen YouTube-Channel, gell? Ne, bring ich das
durcheinander? Ne, doch, genau. Da sind manchmal ganz brauchbare Sachen dabei. Jetzt mache ich
gerade CS50. Was ist denn CS50? Ist das dieses Hover? Ja, ist es. Ich habe gerade nachgeguckt,
ob man das braucht. Keine Ahnung. Wenn ich das durchziehe und abschließe, würde ich meine
Situation dann evaluieren. Ah, man sieht, dass du BWL-Zeug gemacht hast im Vorfeld. Niemand
anderes würde schreiben, ich würde meine Situation dann evaluieren und dann überlegen,
eventuell danach in Teilzeit ein Bootcamp zu machen. Was hältst du davon bzw. kannst du Bootcamp? Ne,
kann ich nicht. Weder Pro noch Contra, weil ich nie ein Bootcamp gemacht habe. Also, keine Ahnung.
Chatgill, was sagt ihr dazu? Also, ich bin der Meinung, man kann das auch alles daheim selbst
lernen ohne Bootcamp. Vielleicht geht es mit einem Bootcamp schneller. Keine Ahnung. Mir
persönlich würden andere Menschen im Bootcamp auf den Sack gehen. Das Beste, was ich mir immer
vorstellen kann zum Programmieren lernen ist, man hat vielleicht das ein oder andere Projekt,
was man persönlich interessant findet, sucht sich die Programmiersprache und Technologie dazu aus
und fängt an. Ja, im Prinzip sagt der Chat das, was ich auch gerade gesagt habe. Was für Bereiche
interessieren dich denn? Sind es eher Frontend-Web-Interface-Sachen? Sind das eher serverseitige
Backend-Geschichten? Ist es irgendwie Machine Learning? Ist es Microcontroller-Programmieren?
Was sind denn so die Bereiche, die dir gefallen? Vielleicht sind es auch Windows-Desktop-Anwendungen.
Was sind die Bereiche, die dir gefallen? Und in dem Bereich würde ich mir tatsächlich die beste
Technologie raussuchen und einfach anfangen. Und mach dir einen GitHub-Account, wenn du ein
bisschen was auf die Reihe bekommst und wenn du dich bewirbst, kannst du den mit verlinken. Das
kommt immer gut an. Sogar bei mir und ich bin nicht hauptberuflicher Softwareentwickler, kam
das gut an, dass ich ein GitHub-Account habe. Wir haben sogar über manche Projekte gesprochen auf
meinem GitHub-Account im Vorstellungsgespräch. Das ist übrigens auch der einzige Grund, warum ich
meine Projekte ordentlich sortiert habe auf GitHub. Das wird nie wieder vorkommen, außer
ich bewerbe mich mal wieder neu. Damals war White Paper Happy Background noch nicht drin. Wir haben uns
sogar hier drüber unterhalten, über Elektroauto-Kram. Also das kann ich nur empfehlen.
Ja, also erzähl mal, was die Bereiche sind, die dir gefallen. Da kann man vielleicht ein bisschen
mehr zu sagen. Umfrage für was? An das Trinken erinnern. Exzellent. Umfrage für was? Ob Bootcamps
sich lohnen. Achso, ja. Okay, das ist eine gute Idee. Das können wir tatsächlich machen. Wie heißt
das richtig? Lohnen sich, wie nennt man sowas? Programmierbootcamps? Wie heißt denn sowas? Ich
weiß keine Ahnung, wie sich sowas nennt. Codingbootcamps. Schreibt man Bootcamps zusammen
oder auseinander? Zusammen. Ja. Was machen wir da für Anfang? Ja, nein, vielleicht. Kommts drauf an.
Okay. Start. Chat-Gem. Bist du überhaupt noch da? Wir hatten das gefragt. Demodimi. Achso, ich habe
natürlich zu Beginn etwas mit Python und JavaScript. Das ist eine gute Sache zum Anfang.
Aber finde ich grundsätzlich auch interessant. Aber im FE sehe ich mich theoretisch. Was ist
denn FE? Finance? Ne. Frontend-Engineer. Frontend? Ah, Frontend sehe ich mich theoretisch nicht. Okay.
Ja, dann würde ich sagen, es ist Zeit, sich mit .NET und C-Sharp zu beschäftigen, wo wir uns ja
einig sind, dass es die beste Programmiersprache ist. Aber ich glaube, du musst erst mal den
Bereich finden, der dir am meisten Bock macht und dir gefällt, weil dann kannst du dir auch ein
paar Projekte überlegen. Sei es, vielleicht hast du ja mega Bock auf Heimautomatisierung oder sowas
und willst Home-Assistent-Plugins bauen in Python. Kann ja auch sein. Oder vielleicht willst du
irgendwelche Machine-Learning-Sachen machen, Microcontroller programmieren. Es gibt ja tausend
Varianten, was du machen kannst. Ich glaube, das Wichtigste ist jetzt erst mal rauszufinden,
welcher Bereich dich eigentlich interessiert. Consulting. Es gibt kaum gescheite Consultants.
Okay, der Chat ist der Meinung, es kommt drauf an. Ehrlich gesagt, als ich diese Option mit
reingesetzt habe, war es mir klar, dass die gewinnt. Also die meisten sind der Meinung,
dass Codecamps... Also es gibt kaum jemand, der meint, Codecamps sind Porg. Viele sagen,
alles Blödsinn und kommt drauf an. Next. Okay, jetzt gucken wir uns mal an,
how er einen 32-Bit-Computer inside Terraria gebaut hat. Ich würde sagen, dass das so ohne
weiteres gar nicht möglich ist. Aber prüfe... Wie könnte man das auf Deutsch sagen? Prüfe mich,
prüfe mich falsch. Jetzt übertreibt das aber ein bisschen. Okay, er hat was gebaut in Terraria,
wo man Pong drauf spielen kann. Dramatische Musik. Zum Glück, zum Glück alte Musik.
What the fuck? Was bin ich hier sehend? Ist das überhaupt noch Terraria? Alter,
jetzt aber gut hier. Er hat es aber schon übertrieben, oder? Mich wundert,
dass das überhaupt läuft. Wahrscheinlich drückt er auf Start und das Game laggt erst mal oder
freest erst mal für 30 Sekunden und dann macht es ein Pong-Update oder so. Und dann freest es
wieder 30 Sekunden und dann macht es wieder einen Pong-Update. Achso, was benutzt er für
den Window-Manager? Das Allerwichtigste. Jaja, ihr habt recht, Chat. Guck mal,
ein i3-Enjoyer. Okay, der hat was drauf. Das sieht man gleich. i3-Enjoyer United hier. So
muss das sein. Warum muss es überhaupt ein 32-Bit-Computer sein? Warum kann es nicht einfach
ein 8-Bit-Computer sein? Für Pong reicht das ja schon. Er bestimmt Arch-User. Bestimmt Arch-User.
Was hat er da oben? Ist das Polybar? Nee, was hat er da oben für eine... Was hat er da oben für
eine Statusleiste, Chat? Es könnte sogar die normale i3-Statusleiste sein. Let's go!
Aber i3-Enjoyer, schon mal nice.
Okay, okay, okay. Nur mal, dass ich das richtig verstanden habe. Also, im Prinzip ist das eine
Mechanik, die nicht dafür gedacht ist, um irgendwelche komplizierten Schaltungen in Terraria
zu bauen. Es ist mehr oder weniger so eine Geschichte von, wir legen ein Kabel, damit wir
uns nicht selbst in die Luft sprengen, wenn wir irgendwas kaputt machen. Okay, nice. Dementsprechend
wird die Performance, beziehungsweise auch das Game, explodieren, wenn du da irgendwie den halben
Bildschirm voll mit baust.
Also quasi, wie er im Thumbnail geschrieben hat, Computer running a game running a computer
running inside a game oder sowas.
Leute, Achtung! Jetzt, jetzt aufpassen, es wird pfeiffertig. Also jetzt brauchen wir
allen IQ, die wir haben, dass wir das checken können. High IQ only.
Es war eben was, wie viel Stunden er ingame hat, stand da eben irgendwo. Wo denn? Hier, hier davor noch?
Hier oder hier? 600 Stunden? Hier meinst du?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Ach hier, 8372 Stunden. Terraria Pro Gamer am Start.
Okay, das ist wirklich viel. Also der hat ziemlich genau ein Jahr durchgehend Terraria gespielt.
Das ist mal Dedication, hä?
Diese sind kleine individuelle Einheiten, die mehrere Inputs reinbeziehen und eine Ausgabe
ausführen, aufgrund von einer sehr einfachen Logik. Computer werden von extensiven Kombinationen
dieser Gäte gemacht. Terraria hat traditionelle Logik-Gäte, wie AND und OR, aber für komplizierte
und frustrierende Zeitungsgründe sind diese unglaublich schwer zu arbeiten.
Anstatt, für mein Computer, benutze ich ausschließlich eine andere Art von Gate, die so aussieht.
Es gibt drei Teile in jeder dieser Gäte, die Input, die State und die Ausgabe.
Hier sieht man, wie man die Fibonacci-Nummeren kalkuliert. Der A-Register zeigt den aktuellen
Wert in der Sequenz und B hält das Nächste, beide binäre. Ich habe die decimalen Versionen
unten angezeigt.
Um herauszufinden, wie es funktioniert, sprechen wir ein wenig über...
...wie Computer auf der Rückseite funktionieren.
Computer, zumindest in hohen Funktionalitäten, sind überraschend simpel.
Vorstellen Sie sich einen Computer als eine Kombination, in der man die Fibonacci-Nummeren
und die Ausgabe der Gäte ausführen kann.
Jeden Moment, wenn die Tür gedrückt wird, wird im Akkustikcomputer die ganz tatsächliche
Schrift der Liste übertragen.
So wird die Ergebnisse auf das häcksliche Papier geschrieben, falls es verwendbar sein könnte.
Die nächsten zwei Monate die Tür gedrückt wird...
...die Gäte werden von der Lenovo ARGB-W Bird.
Und warum hat er einen riesen Taschenrechner?
Der Instruktionen-Pointer.
Warum machst du keinen?
Ich brauche großen Taschenrechner selten.
Ich habe einen Taschenrechner, aber so einen 2 Meter großen Taschenrechner brauche ich
selten.
Okay, halben Meter großen Taschenrechner.
Du musst den Knopf drücken bis zu Milliarden von Malen pro Sekunde.
Die Liste der Instruktionen ist das Programm, das du exekutierst.
Der Kalkulator heißt die Arithmetische Logik-Unit oder ALU.
Das Schraubtisch entspricht den Registrieren, die wie temporäre Flaschen sind, in denen
Nummern zwischen Kalkulationen gesammelt werden.
Letzteres, all das Daten, das zwischen diesen Komponenten überprüft wird, wird hier geschrieben,
in einer menschenleeren Form.
Aber weil Computer nur Eins und Zero interpretieren können, wird alles in irgendeiner Art binärer
Form dargestellt.
Wie genau diese Instruktionen in Eins und Zero enkodiert werden, wird das Instruktionen-Set
genannt.
Es gibt noch einen weiteren Komponent, den ich zu diesem Modul hinzufügen möchte.
Um die Flüge von Daten zwischen diesen Modulen zu organisieren, ist etwas, das die Kontroll-Unit
betrifft, die von den anderen Komponenten sagt, was und wann zu tun ist.
Das ist so ähnlich wie bei mir, diese Komponenten in der Demonstration zusammen zu interfacieren.
Das sieht alles ziemlich ausgewertet aus, aber man kann genau das sehen, was ich in meinem
Prototypen gemacht habe.
Es gibt genug Memory für 32 Instruktionen, jede 8 Bits lang.
Es gibt eine ALU, die arithmetische Instruktionen, z.B. Addition, exekutiert, und es liest und
schreibt zu einer Paire von Registrieren, die A und B genannt werden.
Die meisten anderen Dinge sind die Kontroll-Unit.
Natürlich ist es nicht offensichtlich, wie brechen es so herunter hilft.
All we've done is take one hard problem and converted it into 5 other also hard problems.
It feels like trying to cure yourself of syphilis by infecting yourself with malaria.
It seems crazy like we're getting nowhere, but it actually somehow works.
A lot of computer science is basically that though, breaking hard problems into more manageable
chunks.
Das stimmt.
Unlike the open-ended task of building a computer, each of these units have very well-defined
inputs and outputs.
For example, to make a circuit that adds two numbers, we know the exact rules that govern
addition and we just have to get clever in how we hook up the gates to match these rules,
just like how we did for the combination lock earlier.
This is a compact circuit to add two 1-bit numbers.
Obviously.
Cringe, wer das nicht erkennt, dass das einfach zwei Nummern zusammenzählt.
Das ist eigentlich total offensichtlich.
Is a compact circuit to add two 1-bit numbers.
There were a lot of problems with this first prototype, as expected.
Remember how I mentioned that only this specific kind of logic gate should be used?
Making this prototype was where I realized why the other ones don't work, but not before
some extensive cranial agitation on my part for a few minutes.
The instruction set I used was custom-made and very limited.
I was literally adding new operation codes on a spreadsheet when I implemented them.
For my full-scale computer, I wanted to implement a real-world instruction set.
I don't have time to go into exactly what this means, but it's a massive difference
that enables most of what I've done here, but it involves far more work in ensuring
complete compliance to a strict standard.
Finally, performance-wise, my prototype was pathetic.
My target for the full computer was 100 kilobytes of memory and far faster running speeds.
At this point, I had a plan for the full-scale project, now I just needed to implement it.
Building the full computer took a long time.
Like, a really long time.
There are mods and editors that enable some copy-and-paste functionality, but any kind
of circuitry that isn't exactly copied has to be redone by hand.
All in all, it took around three months of active development.
But along the way, I learned a huge amount about digital logic and CPU design.
Surprisingly, spending three months playing Terraria has improved my career prospects.
After all that, though, I had finally done it.
I had designed and built a complete computer, from scratch, in Terraria.
To give you a sense of scale, here's the prototype I talked about earlier.
Here's how big it is when compared to the real size of the final version.
Looking back at projects like this in hindsight always gives the sense that things just work
perfectly in the first try.
But they really, really don't.
I wanted to give you a small taste of the pain I experienced debugging this behemoth.
So let's look at this circuit for example.
You can see the problem, right?
No?
Well, you can at least tell the difference between the right and the left side of the
screen.
Okay, that's a rhetorical question, he doesn't want us to see it, but maybe we'll see it.
Okay, that's incorrect.
He's standing here, he's standing in front of it, maybe that's the problem here somewhere.
Correct.
I have no idea.
I have absolutely no idea.
Right and wrong version, right?
Still no?
Okay, fine.
Let's zoom in a bit.
I'm sure now you can see the difference, right?
I'll even...
I don't see any difference.
The color of the green cables is different.
Huh?
No.
Here, green and green are a bit different.
But that's the same there.
Okay, I have no idea.
He'll show us right now.
What?
I don't even recognize it when I know where it is.
Oh, actually, look.
Green?
Bright green?
Dark green?
Yeah, but seriously.
Okay, that's really mean.
That's not possible.
Yeah, Grinch, who doesn't see that?
And that's not possible.
That's what I thought.
I almost suspected that.
Because these things aren't meant for something like that.
And that's why they're not meant for something like that.
That's what I thought.
That it would take 30 seconds,
then produce 1 FPS in Pong and then...
That's also true.
Crazy, man.
The people have completely taken it apart and analyzed it.
Somehow it has to work.
Why do they all have such crazy setups?
I can already imagine two screens like the evil Hacker Man.
They all have a screen at the top, a high-end screen.
And one thing that always confuses me is
that they often have keyboards without Numblock.
Sometimes even without arrow keys.
Sure, I get it.
You don't necessarily need it.
It takes up less space.
But I actually like the Numblock for typing.
Numblock is Pong.
Okay, he didn't just build the computer.
He also built a Terraria mod
so that it's possible to build a computer in Terraria.
You could also say it's cheating.
Yes, you could.
But if it doesn't work the other way.
So almost 5 kHz.
There is a Minecraft mod for Minecraft that can play Minecraft.
Yes, but that's really cheating.
Because it lets the virtual box run under the hood
and only maps the graphics in Minecraft.
That's really cheating.
Not this one.
Not really.
He still uses the in-game stuff.
Just better implemented for this use case.
What? Rust?
Finally! There they are again.
Rust is the reason why this works.
I don't understand what I'm seeing there.
GitHub Actions
builds stuff
then a binary file
the txt file is read
At least he did it in a good programming language.
I've also written a high-level and easy-to-use Rust application driver
set up the official RISC-V instruction set compliance test to run in-game
and even published a Docker image with continuous integration
to automatically run regression tests whenever the world has changed.
He's probably looking for a new job.
That's a nice project.
You can apply for it.
That's cool.
But it's also a nice example
of how much
how much
complexity can evolve.
Ich meine das ist schon cool oder?
Das ist schon nice, dass das funktioniert.
Ich habe mir vorgestellt, dass ich ein Videospiel live in einem General-Purpose-Computer spielen werde, das ich in einem anderen Videospiel gemacht habe.
Ein weiteres Programm, das ich aus meinem Computer geschrieben habe, ist Conway's Game of Life.
Das Game of Life ist eine Reihe von extrem einfachen Regeln, die faszinierende Formen erzeugen, wenn sie wieder zu einem Grid von Zellen, die entweder lebendig oder tot sind, verwendet werden.
Hier kann man es in der Spielzeit sehen.
Leider, weil es sehr komputationlich teuer ist, läuft es nicht sehr schnell.
Selbst nachdem ich das Programm für die Geschwindigkeit sehr viel optimiert habe, ist diese Aufnahme 240 mal schneller.
Ich habe das Beste für das Letzte geschafft.
Bis jetzt hat alles, was ich gezeigt habe, ziemlich einfache 2D-Programme gewesen.
Aber was, wenn man in die dritte Dimension reinkommen könnte?
Erstaunlich ist, dass man sogar auf einem Computer, der so resourcelimitiert ist, das machen kann.
Seht, dass dies nicht...
Na, wird doch Zeit für den GCC und Java und Linux und Minecraft da drinnen.
...ein Prerecorded-Pixel-Video spielen.
Es bildet tatsächlich ein ganzes 3D-Welt aus der Perspektive eines bestimmten XYZ-Koordinaten und zeigt es auf dem Bildschirm.
Wie bei dem Game of Life...
Ich meine, es ist schon fast Doom, ja?
...ein bisschen zu langsam, um in Real-Time zu laufen, da es 45 Sekunden dauert, nur um ein einzelnes Ding zu bilden.
Ah, okay. Moment, das ist nicht mal ein FPS.
Das ist, ähm...
Ja, keine Ahnung, was das ist, aber...
45 Sekunden für ein FPS.
Ich kann hier aber nicht vollständig ausdrücken.
Ein Freund von mir hat dieses super effiziente Programm geschrieben und alles, was ich getan habe, war, es für diesen Computer zu optimieren.
Obwohl es noch nicht ganz eine einfache Doom-Klone ist, sind wir viel näher dran, als ich erwartete, am Anfang des Projekts.
Krass. Aber trotzdem heftig. Also, dass das möglich ist...
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, er muss Minecraft inside Terraria laufen lassen.
Es ist ein bisschen wie ein einfacher Arduino-Programm.
Und ich würde mich freuen, wenn er mir mehr Programme schickt.
Wenn ihr so weit gekommen seid, danke für's Zuschauen.
Bitte liken, abonnieren, kommentieren und...
Ich weiß nicht, starten Sie mein GitHub?
Wenn Sie sich die Details interessieren...
Ich würde starren, wenn ich könnte.
Mache ich nachher im Stream.
Das hat er verdient.
Das ist krasser Scheiß, Alter, was...
Fuck, die Leute...
Flipmouse, hat er noch mehr dazu?
Nö.
Echt komplett gestörtes Zeug.
Wahnsinn.
FileFat...
Die Leute sind ja auch extrem...
FileFat reicht ja dafür schon gar nicht mehr aus.
Ultra-High-IQ.
Google hat auch Zip-Domains reinvented.
Leute, ich hab Hunger wie Sau.
Also, wir machen Folgendes heute.
Ich geh jetzt was essen.
Und dann ist die Frage, ob ich das hinkriege noch.
Also, wenn ich die Aufnahme hinbekommen hab...
Und die anderen Sachen, dann machen wir heute Abend vielleicht noch Bastel-Stream.
Ansonsten machen wir das irgendwann unter der Woche.
Muss ich mal gucken.
Aber vielleicht klappt das heute Abend noch.
Was wird gebastelt?
Wir versuchen die 9-Euro-Steckdose zu flashen.
Und gucken, ob das mit ZigBee und dem Thermostat geht.
Und solche Geschichten.
Aber erstmal gucken wir, dass wir die Steckdose geflasht kriegen.
Die hat ein ESP8266 drauf.
Also prinzipiell sollte das möglich sein.
Okay, Chat-Gear. Wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut. Bis dann.
See you.